Programming Throwdown Episode 184 Asynchronous programming Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. This is going to be a fun topic. I think this is something that, I don't think they teach this uh well you know this gets back to my like i took so many theoretical classes i
Programming Throwdown 第184期，异步编程。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。这将是一个有趣的话题。我觉得这东西，我不认为他们教得很好，嗯，你知道，这让我想起我上了那么多理论课，我
didn't really take anything practical in college but but but they didn't uh i don't remember learning about this at all in college but it's extremely important and useful so i'm excited for us to get into it um but before we do all that i wanted to talk about something that kind of blew my mind that happened recently to someone in our neighborhood okay so imagine you get a call and it's your voice like it's actually oh actually I don't know if it literally was his voice or if it was just a voice of a child his age but basically it's it's this voice telling her it sound like her son saying hey I am uh actually I'm not gonna say her son's name even if I could remember it but I'm so and so your actual son right and you know I fell and I need some money to like you know help me get to the hospital or whatever right And it's a scam, but it's like in your family member's voice. Like they've cloned their voice and it says it's from them because they probably go on your Facebook and figure out if you've ever posted publicly like, hey, me and my son, it's just
在大学里并没有学到什么实用的东西，但我真的不记得在大学里学过这个，但它非常重要且有用，所以我很兴奋我们能深入探讨它。嗯，但在我们做这一切之前，我想谈谈最近发生在我们邻居身上的一件让我大吃一惊的事情。好吧，想象一下你接到一个电话，那是你孩子的声音，就像，哦，其实我不知道那是不是真的是他的声音，还是只是一个和他年龄相仿的孩子的声音，但基本上就是这个声音在告诉她，听起来像她儿子，说嘿，我，嗯，其实我不会说她儿子的名字，即使我记得，但我是某某某，你真正的儿子，对吧？你知道，我摔倒了，我需要一些钱来，你知道，帮我去医院什么的，对吧？这是一个骗局，但它用的是你家人的声音。就像他们克隆了他们的声音，并声称是他们打来的，因为他们可能会去你的Facebook，看看你是否曾经公开贴出过，嘿，我和我儿子，就
say Doug. So they call you and it's like, hey, it's Doug. You know, I fell and I need you to wire me some money or something like that. So, you know, the person knew was a scam, but it really kind of blew my mind. I've been getting a lot of AI scams on my phone where they text me. I don't say I want to fall for it in the sense like I didn't lose anything. But the first time it happened, it was like, hey, you know, I'm in Austin at the 6th Street parking garage. Where are you?
说是Doug。所以他们打电话给你，就像，嘿，我是Doug。你知道，我摔倒了，我需要你给我汇点钱之类的。所以，你知道，那个人知道这是一个骗局，但这真的让我大吃一惊。我的手机上一直收到很多AI诈骗信息。我不会说我会上当，因为我没有损失任何东西。但第一次发生时，就像，嘿，你知道，我在奥斯汀的第六街停车场。你在哪？
And I was like, well, who is this? It's like, oh, you didn't save my number? I'm like, okay, no, I didn't save your number. Who is this? It's like, oh, I'm Jolene or something, whatever. The name was the name I didn't recognize. And I was like, okay, yeah, this is clearly, but when I feel like, you know, I couldn't prove that that one's AI, but I feel like people are using AI to scam people.
我说，嗯，这是谁？他说，哦，你没存我的号码吗？我说，好吧，不，我没存你的号码。这是谁？他说，哦，我是Jolene之类的，不管是谁。那个名字我没认出来。我就说，好吧，是的，这显然是，但当我感觉，你知道，我无法证明那个是AI，但我感觉人们正在利用AI来诈骗。
And the one over the phone was definitely some AI thing. And, yeah, I just wanted to throw that out there and get your thoughts. It's pretty mind-blowing. Yeah, be careful. I mean, scams in general are... kind of an well, bad but interesting topic.
电话里的那个绝对是某种AI。而且，是的，我只是想提一下，听听你的想法。这太令人震惊了。是的，要小心。我的意思是，诈骗总的来说是……一种，嗯，糟糕但有趣的话题。
I don't know how you say that. Like it's actually really unfortunate and scammers suck. I don't really understand. Anyway, whatever. Listen aside. But I think that...
我不知道该怎么说。这真的很不幸，骗子真可恶。我不太明白。总之，不管怎样。撇开这些不谈。但我认为……
I mean, it's big money, right? That's whatever. Yeah, but still, like, I, a lot of the people that they scam, right? So part of it that's confusing to me is like, oh, this is an obvious scam. And it's like, well,
我的意思是，这是大钱，对吧？不管怎样。是的，但仍然，像，我，他们诈骗的很多人，对吧？所以其中让我困惑的一部分是，哦，这是一个明显的骗局。然后就像，嗯，
that's part of it, though. They want to kind of weed out people who are going to be, like they want someone who's not going to catch on later. And so, you know, they want someone who isn't going to ask questions. Like you're insistent of who is this or potentially looking for you to fall into it. It's sort of the, you know, when you're sometimes when you're young, you tell these jokes where like you're hoping the person will give a certain reaction so that you can sort of like say something funny in response.
这也是其中的一部分。他们想剔除那些会，他们想要一个以后不会发现的人。所以，你知道，他们想要一个不会问问题的人。就像你坚持问这是谁，或者可能在等着你上钩。这有点像，你知道，当你年轻的时候，有时你会讲这些笑话，希望对方会有某种反应，这样你就可以在回应中说些有趣的话。
And so they're sort of, instead of saying who is this and they say, oh, you didn't save my number and go, oh, is it Sarah? And then like, yeah, it's Sarah. and then you're like, oh, it's Sarah, but it's not, right? Like, they were just hoping you would say a name first. And like you said, it can be really easy to fall on these. And I do worry, like you're pointing out, AI on two fronts, scaling these out so that they don't even need someone to be attentive to all of these different threads that, you know, they can just mass do them and have auto responders and keep people busy
所以他们有点像，与其说这是谁，不如说，哦，你没存我的号码，然后说，哦，是Sarah吗？然后就像，是的，我是Sarah。然后你就说，哦，是Sarah，但其实不是，对吧？他们只是希望你先说出一个名字。就像你说的，陷入这些骗局真的很容易。我确实很担心，就像你指出的那样，AI在两个方面，扩展这些骗局，这样他们甚至不需要有人关注所有这些不同的线索，你知道，他们可以大规模地进行，并有自动回复，让人们忙碌
until they like figure out something is scary. And then the voice cloning, eventually video cloning, I the video cloning the video stuff is getting to the point where everyone goes oh it's so obvious it's so obvious and they do like some frame by frame like look at the and it's like but who in the small little window when you're scrolling through social media can see like this frame by frame pixel analysis where you know the pinky finger glitches out for for one frame or whatever it's you know I remember you and I discussing on this the Will Smith eating spaghetti oh yeah that's right that wasn't that long ago yeah now now like I saw some video from a football game over the weekend where one of the coaches had an issue and somebody made an AI video of him like like basically super vulgarity like dropping like saying how bad it was or whatever and it just turns out it was like completely fake and they the they said it underneath but you had to like click it and look for it a lot of people probably re-shared it thinking was funny like look the coach like basically going off on on reporters and stuff and so
直到他们发现有些不对劲。然后是声音克隆，最终是视频克隆，我，视频克隆，视频内容正变得让每个人都说，哦，这太明显了，太明显了，他们做了一些逐帧分析，看看，就像，但在社交媒体上滚动时，谁能在那个小窗口里看到这种逐帧像素分析，你知道小指在某一帧里故障了之类的，你知道，我记得你和我讨论过威尔·史密斯吃意大利面那个，哦，是的，没错，那没过多久，是的，现在，就像我周末在足球比赛中看到的一些视频，其中一位教练出了点问题，有人制作了一个他的AI视频，基本上是非常粗俗的，比如他说这有多糟糕之类的，结果发现这完全是假的，他们在下面说了，但你必须点击它并寻找它，很多人可能转发了它，认为这很有趣，就像看教练基本上在对记者发火之类的，所以
it's becoming more and more prevalent and it only takes you being off guard for for sort of a moment to get wrapped up on this. So yeah, definitely be careful. But I actually have a full observation about this. So you mentioned like, you know, we all kind of go, oh yeah, voice cloning. It's dangerous.
它变得越来越普遍，你只需要稍微放松警惕，就会被卷入其中。所以，是的，一定要小心。但我实际上对此有一个完整的观察。所以你提到了，你知道，我们都说，哦，是的，声音克隆。这很危险。
You and I have lots of, you know, audio out there. It's, you know, whatever. But now like you see demos on YouTube or people showing, hey, from even just maybe 10 seconds of an arbitrary sentence, they can sort of You can use a different voice or clone the person's voice, you know, do voice-to-voice sort of transition. Yeah. So I've seen these before. So then I wanted to do this for basically like an audio enhancement thing.
你和我有很多，你知道，音频在外面。这，你知道，不管怎样。但现在就像你在YouTube上看到的演示，或者人们展示，嘿，甚至可能只需要10秒的任意句子，他们就可以，你可以使用不同的声音或克隆人的声音，你知道，进行语音到语音的转换。是的。所以我以前见过这些。所以我当时想把这个用于基本上像音频增强的东西。
I had some audio I had recorded somewhere and I was like, oh, I want to use voice clone, which I know should be possible to like feed it my own voice from a podcast recording or something high quality, feed it the like not good quality and have it basically reread that stuff in the high-quality voice. which is a use case as supposedly possible. And then you immediately bump into the fact that, like, it's actually really difficult. Like, as much as people say, oh, there's going to be this. It's non-trivial. Like, I guess there's a lot of pay solutions, but it's often unclear if the paid solutions are any good
我有一些在某处录制的音频，我想，哦，我想使用声音克隆，我知道这应该是可能的，比如从播客录音或高质量的东西中输入我自己的声音，输入那些质量不好的音频，让它基本上用高质量的声音重新朗读那些内容。这是一个据称可能的用例。然后你立刻就会发现，这实际上非常困难。就像人们说的那样，哦，会有这个。这并不简单。我想有很多付费解决方案，但通常不清楚付费解决方案是否真的好
or if they're just like the open source stuff that someone's charging for. But like cobbling together all of the like, you go download this model, you run it on comfy UI, you do that. Like, it's still in the realm of like, this is reasonably difficult to access. So for all of these AI things, everyone's like, oh, it's so easy to do this. And then, or generating an AI video. Like we all know, we've all seen some crazy AI video that was hilarious or partly convincing.
或者它们只是别人收费的开源东西。但是，把所有东西拼凑在一起，比如，你去下载这个模型，你在Comfy UI上运行它，你做那个。这仍然处于，这很难访问的领域。所以对于所有这些AI东西，每个人都说，哦，做这个太容易了。然后，或者生成一个AI视频。就像我们都知道，我们都看过一些疯狂的AI视频，它们很搞笑或部分令人信服。
And then you go try to do it. And I don't know, maybe I'm just not smart enough or paying enough attention. But they seem a little cherry picked. Like people may have gone through a lot of work to cherry pick the one convincing video. And if you go do it, you think it's going to be magical and it's actually a little disappointing. That's been my observation. Yeah, I think there's two things there. One is, you know, definitely it's, the open source stuff is not trivial to get up and running.
然后你去尝试做它。我不知道，也许我只是不够聪明或不够专注。但它们看起来有点经过精心挑选。就像人们可能花了很多功夫去挑选那个令人信服的视频。如果你去尝试，你以为它会很神奇，但实际上有点令人失望。这就是我的观察。是的，我认为那里有两件事。一是，你知道，绝对是，开源的东西要运行起来并不简单。
I do think that the paid solutions are like, you know, pretty accessible, but, but you're also right that you often have to iterate a lot and you have to get, it's almost a skill in and of itself, getting it to sort of behave and feeding in the right sort of negative prompts so that it doesn't go off the rails and all of. that. So, yeah, that's a whole skill in and of itself. Yeah, someday, it is getting better fast. So I think we are getting close. But it's one of those things where I was thinking about this the other day. It's like, if you could describe where we are right now with AI, people would be like, oh, that's going to be so magical. It's going to change everything. The world, like, and then we got here and it's like, oh, huh. You know, like, I don't know. Like, an AI could clearly probably pass the traditional sort of turning test. I maybe that's controversial.
我确实认为付费解决方案是，你知道，相当容易访问的，但，但你也是对的，你通常必须进行很多迭代，你必须得到，这几乎是一项技能本身，让它表现得好，并输入正确的负面提示，这样它就不会失控等等。所以，是的，那是一项完整的技能。是的，总有一天，它正在快速变好。所以我认为我们快要接近了。但这就像我前几天想的那样。就像，如果你能描述我们现在在AI方面所处的位置，人们会说，哦，那将是如此神奇。它将改变一切。世界，就像，然后我们到了这里，就像，哦，嗯。你知道，就像，一个AI显然可能通过传统的图灵测试。也许这有争议。
And then now it turns out like, oh, yeah, but it didn't just solve all of life's problems. Like, you know. Yeah.
然后现在结果是，哦，是的，但它并没有解决所有生活中的问题。就像，你知道。是的。
Yeah, I think that, to double doubt on that, I think AI is just not going to create the kind of monetary value that people thought it would. You know, like the thing about it is,
是的，我认为，为了加倍怀疑，我认为AI只是不会创造人们认为它会创造的那种货币价值。你知道，关于它的事情是，
the reason why Fang got so incredibly rich is that now people can like be super productive anywhere you know and so like you could be waiting in line for a ride at Disney and like working you know like you could be answering emails talking to people on like that was something that in you know 1999 you couldn't do if you were waiting in line for an hour at Disney you couldn't do your job right and so you know a combination of of Apple Google for search these other things like allowed people to be like super productive um you know when they're even when they're idle and uh and for AI it might it might do that um but it hasn't done that yet it might take a lot longer to get there okay we're way
Fang之所以变得如此富有，是因为现在人们可以在任何地方超级高效，你知道，所以你可以在迪士尼排队等候游乐设施时工作，你知道，你可以回复邮件，与人交谈，就像那是1999年你无法做到的事情，如果你在迪士尼排队等候一个小时，你无法完成你的工作，对吧？所以，你知道，苹果、谷歌搜索和其他东西的结合，让人们即使在闲暇时也能超级高效，嗯，你知道，对于AI，它可能，它可能做到这一点，但它还没有做到，可能需要更长的时间才能达到那里，好吧，我们离
off the AI scam thing but i have heard some recent interviews along the lines and they said actually like the the the thing the like what will be the inflection point or the turning point is when all of these advances sort of make it into robotics. I could see that. Do you think that's like a different economic equation? Like when not just oh you can be taking the AI and making programmers more effective or making people's email responses better or like sure all of those things maybe economic value is a little like but like if you had the level of improvement we've seen there in sort of like robotics. Is that going to be a major? or unlock it totally totally yeah so here's a very simple example like think how many parents
AI诈骗的事情太远了，但我最近听到了一些相关的采访，他们说实际上，像，那个，像，什么是拐点或转折点，是当所有这些进步进入机器人技术时。我能预见到这一点。你认为这是一种不同的经济等式吗？就像当不仅仅是，哦，你可以利用AI让程序员更有效率，或者让人们的电子邮件回复更好，或者像，当然所有这些事情也许经济价值有点像，但如果你在机器人技术方面看到了我们所看到的改进水平。那会是一个重大的吗？或者完全解锁它，完全，是的，所以这是一个非常简单的例子，想想有多少父母
have to like either changes or work schedule or do something kind of wonky um to just like shuttle their kids around oh yes yeah yeah just driving it's like oh i pick uh one of my kids up from school i drive them to the soccer field and and especially when they get older they don't even want you know they don't want parents to be sitting there like watching the practice yeah exactly It goes in the car, so you can see you. Yeah, yeah. So you either go home then or whatever. Like that's just one example.
必须要么改变工作时间表，要么做一些奇怪的事情，只是为了接送他们的孩子，哦，是的，是的，是的，只是开车，就像，哦，我从学校接我的一个孩子，我开车送他们去足球场，尤其是当他们长大后，他们甚至不想，你知道，他们不想让父母坐在那里看练习，是的，完全正确，在车里，所以你可以看到你。是的，是的。所以你要么回家，要么怎样。这只是一个例子。
Like you could have a robot that goes up and down the street taking everyone's trash to the curb. I mean, there's just so much you get unlocked with robotics. But I think it'll take a while. All right. Yeah, well, let's keep moving through the agenda. All right. So, yeah, don't get scammed. Don't get scammed by AI.
你可以有一个机器人，在街上走来走去，把每个人的垃圾带到路边。我的意思是，机器人技术解锁了很多东西。但我认为这需要一段时间。好吧。是的，好吧，让我们继续议程。好吧。所以，是的，不要被骗。不要被AI诈骗。
Yeah, do be careful. And warn your parents and grandparents or, you know, family like as well who may not be as aware that that's a thing yeah um yeah very true very true all right uh what's the first news of the show all right so i have i have no news this time uh but i do have two good video links that i wanted to to shout out um and so the first one was a recent video by um sebastian i actually didn't look up how to say his last name i i know i'm not going to try I said, log? Log.
是的，要小心。并警告你的父母和祖父母，或者，你知道，家人，他们可能不像你那样意识到这是一个问题，是的，嗯，是的，非常正确，非常正确，好吧，嗯，节目的第一个新闻是什么，好吧，所以我这次没有新闻，但我有两个很好的视频链接，我想大声疾呼，所以第一个是Sebastian最近的一个视频，我实际上没有查怎么说他的姓，我，我知道我不会尝试，我说，Log？Log。
Okay. Anyways, and it's coding adventure, ray tracing glass and caustics. This is a series of videos that Sebastian's been doing. They're sort of like the, in a similar vein as I guess like three blue, one brown. Like, you know, it's like sort of a nice quiet pace, but like deep content and just sort of like working through something. So they're not like five minute YouTube shorts. They're sort of longer form videos.
好吧。总之，这是编码冒险，光线追踪玻璃和焦散。这是Sebastian一直在做的一系列视频。它们有点像，我想类似于三蓝一棕。就像，你知道，这是一种很好的安静节奏，但内容很深，只是在处理一些事情。所以它们不像五分钟的YouTube短片。它们是更长形式的视频。
And he's walking through the process of coding. he's been working on a ray chaser recently but going a little step further than the normal and so in this one he's sort of talking he gets to talk a little bit about like physics physical based rendering and sort of like how glass has certain attributes and indexes of refraction and sort of if you build up from like really simple sort of rules you get very complex interactions almost becomes a physics simulation right like the caustics is the like very bright shiny thing that If you have like a glass object, you get, you know, sort of like rainbow diffusions in some areas. In some areas, you get, you know, like very bright, shiny spots or whatever.
他正在经历编码的过程。他最近一直在研究光线追踪器，但比通常的更进一步，所以在这个视频中，他谈论了一些关于物理基础渲染，以及玻璃如何具有某些属性和折射率，以及如果你从非常简单的规则建立起来，你会得到非常复杂的交互，几乎变成了物理模拟，对吧？焦散是那种非常明亮闪亮的东西，如果你有一个玻璃物体，你会得到，你知道，某种像彩虹扩散的东西。在某些区域，你会得到，你知道，非常明亮、闪亮的点之类的。
And if you play video games, often you won't see those kinds of things because they're not really meant to be simulating physics. They're meant to look nice and run fast. Yeah. But in ray tracing, you can be kind of more physics-based. But a lot of videos on his channel that are just like really, really good. But this one's really nice. And then the reason why I wanted to bring it up here, other than like, you know, I mean, maybe this is really cool to you. It's great background photo.
如果你玩电子游戏，通常你不会看到那种东西，因为它们并不是真的要模拟物理。它们是为了看起来不错并运行得快。是的。但在光线追踪中，你可以更基于物理。但他频道上的很多视频都非常好。但这个真的很好。而且我之所以想在这里提出来，除了，你知道，我的意思是，也许这对你来说真的很酷。这是很棒的背景照片。
This is kind of tends to be the YouTube I watch. I try to explain to people. There's people who watch YouTube and it's like, you know, more the shorts content or entertaining. But there's a lot of this like science engineering kind of stuff out there that I feel is at least a little bit better than I'll just call like brain candy. And it's sort of replacement for, you know, the TV growing up. We were like, what, Bill and I, the science guy or something. that would be like, you know, a little, and even that was high strung, I guess, but, you know, teaching, teaching sort of science concepts in an entertaining way. And there's a bunch of people in
这往往是我看的YouTube。我试着向人们解释。有些人看YouTube，更像是短片内容或娱乐。但外面有很多这种科学工程类的东西，我觉得至少比我称之为大脑糖果的东西要好。它有点像我们成长过程中电视的替代品，我们当时看什么，比尔·奈科学怪人之类的，那会是，你知道，一点点，即使那是高压的，我想，但是，你知道，以一种有趣的方式教授科学概念。而且有一群人
this vein. But I will say that I also began to realize that a lot of the classes I took in university, you can kind of end up not building a curriculum, but if you just watch some of these channels about how microprocessors work or people kind of building their own circuits, some of this stuff about ray tracing, you get a lot of what a traditional, at least when I was in college, sort of like computer science degree would cover. So if you can kind of get through the basics of programming, learning about like graphics, learning about like data structures, he gets into debugging because by necessity he like, oh, here I didn't check the sign properly or I did a dot product and I didn't think about like this set of inputs. And so you actually end up backing your way into a lot of
在这个领域。但我会说，我也开始意识到，我在大学里上的很多课，你最终可能不会建立一个课程，但如果你只是看一些关于微处理器如何工作或者人们自己构建电路的频道，关于光线追踪的一些东西，你会得到很多传统的，至少在我上大学时，计算机科学学位会涵盖的内容。所以如果你能通过编程的基础知识，学习图形，学习数据结构，他会进入调试，因为出于必要，他会，哦，这里我没有正确检查符号，或者我做了一个点积，我没有考虑这组输入。所以你实际上最终会倒退进入很多
that education. And so I think that's really an interesting thing to say if you can, if you find this at all entertaining, I think there's like a definite learning ability that can come here from sort of watching this and sort of seeing how, how they kind of go about problem solving and working through things. And it is a little bit more entertaining than just watching, you know, I don't know if he does it anymore, but not choose to do like live streaming of him programming or whatever. Like, and I guess we'll do. Yeah. Oh, we should do that. No, no, no, no. I don't know. I don't I never made able to watch one of those. This is a more edited form of that.
那种教育。所以我认为这是一个非常有趣的事情，如果你觉得这有一点娱乐性，我认为这里肯定有一种学习能力，可以通过观看这个，看到他们如何解决问题和处理事情。而且它比仅仅看，你知道，我不知道他是否还这样做，但不选择做他编程的直播之类的，要有趣得多。而且我想我们会做的。是的。哦，我们应该那样做。不，不，不，不。我不知道。我从来没能看那些。这是一个更编辑过的版本。
Cool. I'll have to check that out. I used to do a lot of that ray tracing stuff back in college, and it's very fun. All right, my news is actually, okay, so it's kind of related to the voice quoting. Oh, okay. There's a new open source model called Higgs Audio V2. And it's from a company called BOSON AI. And it's like really, really good.
酷。我得去看看。我大学时做过很多光线追踪方面的工作，那非常有趣。好了，我的新闻其实是，好吧，它和语音引用有点关系。哦，好的。有一个新的开源模型叫 Higgs Audio V2。它来自一家叫 BOSON AI 的公司。它真的非常非常棒。
So historically, this company called 11 Labs had been kind of dominating the space. So if you want to do voice cloning, actually 11 labs is something I've never seen before to this day, which is you can describe a voice and then say what you want that voice to say and it'll do it. So you could say, you know, an evil, smelly ogre says, who's in my dungeon? And it'll actually, like, make up a voice for that description and then say who's in my dungeon in that voice that just made up.
历史上，一家叫 11 Labs 的公司一直在这个领域占据主导地位。如果你想做语音克隆，11 Labs 有一个我至今从未见过的功能，那就是你可以描述一个声音，然后说出你想让那个声音说什么，它就能做到。所以你可以说，你知道，一个邪恶、臭烘烘的食人魔说，谁在我的地牢里？它真的会为那个描述编造一个声音，然后用那个刚编造出来的声音说出“谁在我的地牢里”。
This doesn't do that. But... 11 Labs is paid, though, right? 11 Labs is paid. That's right. But this is totally open source, and it can clone a voice. So you give it, you know, an MP3 of you kind of narrating something, and then now it has your voice.
这个做不到这一点。但是……11 Labs 是付费的，对吧？11 Labs 是付费的。没错。但这个是完全开源的，而且它可以克隆声音。所以你给它一个你朗读某段内容的 MP3，然后它就拥有了你的声音。
It could say anything. It handles like, you know, you can do kind of like in a movie script or brackets. You say, you know, laughs or chuckles or whatever, and it'll actually laugh while it's talking. It's really, really, really good. It's definitely just like heads and tails above anything I've seen in the open source world. So I'm going to try and play with it. I have some funny things I want to do. I'm not going to run a scam call center.
它可以说任何话。它能处理，你知道，你可以像在电影剧本或括号里那样，写上“笑”或“轻笑”之类的，它在说话时真的会笑。它真的、真的、真的非常棒。它绝对比我在开源世界中见过的任何东西都要高出一大截。所以我打算试着玩玩它。我有一些有趣的事情想做。我可不会去经营一个诈骗呼叫中心。
Oh, no, no, no, please don't. But I have some other funny things that I would like to do with it. So I'm going to try and mess around with it. But I saw a demo that one of my coworkers presented, where they cloned their own voice, and it sounded really believable. So it's like we're getting to that place you talked about where anyone with the GPU could just do this.
哦，不，不，不，请千万别。但我还有其他一些想用它做的有趣的事情。所以我打算试着摆弄一下。但我看到了我的一位同事演示的 demo，他们克隆了自己的声音，听起来非常逼真。所以我们正处于你所说的那种阶段，任何拥有 GPU 的人都可以做到这一点。
Yeah, so what is? is the, I guess, for examples, like a lot of these, they don't need to be, like, super fast real time. Like, I know they could run an SUV, but I don't feel maybe we're just still too early. So for text LLM's open source, and maybe it's just because I've never spent time. There's something like LM Studio kind of gets there. So there's like a GUI that you download, and then from there, it offers you links. And I help someone in my family was trying to use some offline LLM stuff. And so I was able to walk them. through pretty easily. You go there, it offers you models that are appropriate for your computer
是的，那么什么是？我想，举个例子，很多这类模型不需要超级快的实时性。我知道它们可以在 SUV 上运行，但我感觉也许我们还处于太早期的阶段。对于文本大语言模型的开源来说，也许只是因为我从未花时间研究。像 LM Studio 这样的东西差不多能做到。它有一个你可以下载的图形界面，然后从那里，它为你提供链接。我帮我家里的一位亲戚尝试使用一些离线大语言模型。所以我能很容易地引导他们完成。你到那里，它会为你提供适合你电脑的模型，
tells you if you big, tells you if they're too small, has filtering, then you download it. It gives you the nice traditional sort of like chat GPT style. Like you can type in text in the bottom. It has prompts in. It'll answer. But it has like, you can go deep on it, but it sort of harnesses a bunch of the open source stuff under the hood. So you can do like traditional chat app with one of these offline LLMs. You can switch models midstream, and it'll, like, just feed the context into the new model. Like, it kind of just works as a graphical user interface. But for a lot of these other ones, like the image generation, I don't feel like it's as good.
告诉你模型是否太大，告诉你是否太小，有过滤功能，然后你下载它。它会给你提供那种漂亮的、传统的类似 ChatGPT 的界面。比如你可以在底部输入文本。它有提示词。它会回答。但你可以深入研究它，它在底层利用了一堆开源的东西。所以你可以用这些离线大语言模型之一做传统的聊天应用。你可以在中途切换模型，它会把上下文输入到新模型中。它就像一个图形用户界面一样工作。但对于许多其他模型，比如图像生成，我觉得它没那么好。
Video generation, not at all. These, like, audio ones, sort of, I've never seen anything like that. I feel there's still, like, a bunch of this, maybe we're just still too early, but, like, single front end. So we're audio, right? You're either wanting text. You want, like, the thing, the target, the source. They feel like there's only a few moving pieces. Maybe there's just not enough users,
视频生成，完全不行。这些音频模型，某种程度上，我从未见过类似的东西。我觉得这里仍然有一堆东西，也许我们还处于太早期的阶段，但比如单一的前端。所以我们是音频，对吧？你要么想要文本。你想要，比如那个东西，目标，源。感觉只有几个移动的部分。也许只是用户不够多，
but it feels like it'd be really easy to just build an app that's like a front end and handles like I'm looking at the GitHub link for the one you were just talking about. And it's how to set up conda or virtual environment. But I'm never going to describe to someone in my family how to do these steps. Like they will never be able at this level to use this. Yeah, we're still not quite there yet on the user experience. Totally agree.
但感觉构建一个前端并处理这些的应用会非常容易。我正在看你刚才谈到的那个项目的 GitHub 链接。上面写着如何设置 conda 或虚拟环境。但我永远不会向我家里的人描述如何进行这些步骤。他们永远无法在这个水平上使用它。是的，我们在用户体验方面确实还没到那一步。完全同意。
I think the quality is getting there though. the flux text-to-image model is really, really good. It's mind-blowing. It just needs a better user experience. And the new one, we don't have it in our news, but the new one, Google did Nano Banana or whatever. Have you seen this one, too? I played with it a little.
不过我认为质量正在提升。Flux 文生图模型真的非常非常棒。令人惊叹。它只是需要更好的用户体验。还有那个新的，我们新闻里没有，但那个新的，谷歌做的 Nano Banana 之类的。你也见过这个吗？我稍微玩了一下。
Yeah. Specifically for like image editing tasks. So like saying I have an image and I want to change it in some way, like I was asking it to do like people removal from background. and it works really good. It's kind of scary good. Now that one's paid, right? That's a Google product,
是的。专门针对图像编辑任务。比如我说我有一张图片，我想以某种方式改变它，就像我要求它从背景中移除人物一样。它效果非常好。好得有点吓人。那个是付费的，对吧？那是谷歌的产品，
but still, like, yeah, you're right. We are getting really close on the image stuff. Yeah, totally. Okay, my next news article is a YouTube channel as well. Okay, that's the thing. Anyways, and this is on my, as people have listened to the podcast before, no, machine learning AI is not my background, but understanding sort of how the back propagation works,
但仍然，是的，你说得对。我们在图像方面确实非常接近了。是的，完全同意。好的，我的下一条新闻也是关于一个 YouTube 频道的。好的，就是这样。总之，这是关于我的，正如听过播客的人所知，机器学习 AI 不是我的背景，但理解反向传播是如何工作的，
how the gradient descends and sort of the model trainings is all very like interesting to me. I had a book of the show a little bit ago that, you know, kind of similar or maybe it was even a news article. But I think that I'm continuing to try to learn and sort of work on my back, not just as a, how do you call like practitioner, like user of these things, but trying to understand some underlying thing.
梯度下降以及模型训练是如何进行的，对我来说都非常有趣。我前段时间在节目里推荐过一本书，你知道，类似的，或者甚至可能是一篇新闻文章。但我认为我正在继续尝试学习并努力提升我的背景，不仅仅是作为一个从业者，也就是这些东西的用户，而是试图理解一些底层的东西。
And I think there's some concepts there that can cross apply to other. sort of like traditional computer science sort of applications. So it's just definitely like an interesting thing to learn about. It is pretty wild to see AI go kind of mainstream. It's been just a really weird experience.
我认为其中有一些概念可以交叉应用到其他传统的计算机科学应用中。所以这绝对是一件值得学习的有趣事情。看到 AI 走向主流确实非常疯狂。这真是一种非常奇怪的体验。
Like all these people are now talking about stuff that was like really not that cool that long ago. Yeah. Oh, I'll tell you off that. It's just an observation about that. But I know you've been in the field for very long. You were in the field before it was cool.
就像所有这些人现在都在谈论不久前还不是很酷的东西。是的。哦，我会告诉你关于那个的。这只是一个观察。但我知道你在该领域已经很久了。你在它变酷之前就在这个领域了。
And now it's cool. So like that makes you cool. Uh, maybe. Yeah. I don't know. Or maybe it makes me too early. I don't know. We'll find out. Uh, but too early. Everyone's too early for something, right? That's the thing. So even now, you might be too early if it grows another 10x. So yeah, that's a good point. It's like Bitcoin. Uh, yeah. Well, I wasn't, okay. Yes, that was what I was. Um, okay. Back to my focus. So the channel name is Welsh Labs. Um, and they have a sequence of videos that, um, they were doing called how models learn. So this is the first video. that I have linked in the show notes, you can just look up Welsh labs. It's called the misconception that almost stopped AI. Now, I am not Jason, so I cannot vouch for the sort of like how truthful versus narrative the backstory is or any of that stuff. But they're kind of talking about gradient descent and how if you give the sort of how I
现在它变酷了。所以这让你变酷了。呃，也许吧。是的。我不知道。或者也许这让我太早了。我不知道。我们会找到答案的。呃，但太早了。每个人对某件事都太早了，对吧？就是这样。所以即使现在，如果它再增长 10 倍，你可能还是太早了。所以是的，这是一个好观点。就像比特币一样。呃，是的。好吧，我不是，好的。是的，我就是那个意思。嗯，好的。回到我的重点。所以频道名称是 Welsh Labs。嗯，他们有一系列视频，嗯，他们正在做，叫“模型是如何学习的”。所以这是第一个视频。我在节目笔记中链接了它，你可以直接搜索 Welsh Labs。它叫“差点阻止 AI 的误解”。现在，我不是 Jason，所以我不能保证背景故事的真实性与叙事性，或者任何这类东西。但他们谈论的是梯度下降，以及如果你给出那种我
understand gradient descent to work, the very simple, you kind of heard about it in computer science classes. You've seen it on the internet once or twice. And the way that you would kind of assume it might work, it just feels like you would get stuck in local minima all the time with how big these models are, right? Like these models, the dimensions are really high, the parameter counts are obscene. Like you would just say there's an intuitive. And that was sort of what I thought to. I didn't really understand the unlock of deep learning and sort of like what happened. because in my mind, you know, you kind of picture the 3D
理解梯度下降工作原理的方式，非常简单，你在计算机科学课上听说过它。你在互联网上见过一两次。而你假设它可能工作的方式，感觉就像你会一直陷入局部最小值，因为这些模型太大了，对吧？这些模型，维度非常高，参数数量极其庞大。你会说这有一个直觉。这也是我当时的想法。我并没有真正理解深度学习的解锁以及发生了什么。因为在我脑海中，你知道，你想象那个 3D
scene with all the noise in it and some well in the middle, but how do you get there? How do you know where it is without just searching the whole face? There's the, what is it called the like, it's called a Gaussian, but like that's a sombrero hat function where you kind of get trapped outside of the hat.
场景，里面有所有的噪声，中间有一个井，但你怎么到达那里？你怎么知道它在哪里，而不只是搜索整个空间？有一个，它叫什么来着，它叫高斯分布，但那是一个墨西哥草帽函数，你会被困在帽子外面。
Yes, yeah. So you're right. And I, the video series kind of walks through the same same thing. Like this is the simple explanation about gradient descent. Here's why. it would work, except, like, as you point, gotcha. Like, it doesn't really work. Not really a gotcha.
是的，是的。所以你是对的。而且我，这个视频系列也走过了同样的路。这就是关于梯度下降的简单解释。这就是为什么它会工作，除了，正如你指出的，陷阱。它并没有真正工作。不是真正的陷阱。
Well, it doesn't really work, except, wait, it did work. Why, what happened, you know, like, and they walk through how some of the things about higher dimensional spaces about batch, batching, about some of the techniques that are applied, sort of help actually almost always guarantee you sort of get where you want to go to some degree with, with, you know, obviously probably some caveats, but it just a really well-handled explanation. And they do a couple really interesting things I've not seen before. So rather than just sort of give it as a simple explanation, they actually take some deep models, some like early versions of GPTs and extract some of the layers and sort of talk about what is happening. Sort of like
嗯，它并没有真正工作，除了，等等，它确实工作了。为什么，发生了什么，你知道，就像，他们讲解了关于高维空间、批处理、应用的一些技术是如何帮助你几乎总是保证在某种程度上到达你想去的地方，当然可能有一些注意事项，但这确实是一个处理得很好的解释。而且他们做了一些我以前没见过的非常有趣的事情。所以他们不仅仅是给出一个简单的解释，他们实际上采用了一些深度模型，一些早期版本的 GPT，并提取了一些层，讨论了正在发生的事情。就像
visually saying, hey, at this layer, if we go here in this actual model, maybe not state of the art, you know, I trained it. And this is what you kind of see developing over time as a consequence of this technique. And then later on, even after this, one of the videos is talking about sort of how you would take coordinates and divide them up with a sort of classifier into boundaries for a really complex country boundary. It's one of these ones where like there's a city, which one polygon of the city is a part of one country and the rest is another. It's like some really weird place. And how that as you sort of take these linear equations, stack them up, do these other techniques that you can sort of start approaching a generalized
视觉上说，嘿，在这一层，如果我们在这个实际模型中去这里，也许不是最先进的，你知道，我训练了它。这就是你随着时间的推移，作为这种技术的结果所看到的发展。然后在这之后，其中一个视频谈论了你如何获取坐标，并用一种分类器将它们划分为边界，用于一个非常复杂的国家边界。这是那种其中一个城市，城市的一个多边形属于一个国家，其余部分属于另一个国家的情况。这就像一些非常奇怪的地方。以及当你堆叠这些线性方程，做这些其他技术时，你如何开始接近一个广义的
representation of even very, very complex sort of shapes and spaces. And I just really think it was well handled. It really helped me. It's one of those things like I kind of had to watch it again just to kind of like, oh, okay, I see where it's going. But definitely also kind of entertaining. So if you, I guess like me, have some understanding of some of these things, but there's a, there's like a gap, right? There's a goal from, okay, I kind of know what gradient descent is.
即使是非常、非常复杂的形状和空间的表示。我真的认为它处理得很好。它真的帮助了我。这是那种我不得不重看一遍才能明白“哦，好的，我明白它要去哪里了”的事情之一。但绝对也很有趣。所以如果你，我想像我一样，对其中一些事情有一些了解，但有一个差距，对吧？有一个目标，从“好的，我大概知道什么是梯度下降”，
I could have a casual conversation about it, but how that ends up getting applied to giving us, you know, these AI models that we have today is there's some steps, missing steps in between and this isn't going to take you all the way or make you sort of like able to design state of art models or improve them, but giving you better glimpses into sort of some of the techniques that are used to cross that chasm. Yeah, totally. Yes, this is really interesting. I think it is pretty remarkable that it works.
我可以就此进行随意的交谈，但它是如何最终被应用到给我们提供我们今天拥有的这些 AI 模型的，中间有一些步骤，缺失的步骤，这不会带你走完全程，或者让你能够设计最先进的模型或改进它们，但让你更好地瞥见用于跨越那道鸿沟的一些技术。是的，完全同意。是的，这真的很有趣。我认为它能工作确实非常了不起。
I will say that people get hung up on a lot of these, like, it's not optimal or, you know, theoretically this can't work or doesn't work or, et cetera. And my response to that is, like, it just has to be better than what's out there now. And so if what's out there now is nothing, it just has to be better than nothing. And so the bar is just a lot lower than like the theorists want it to be. I actually think the thing that almost made AI not happen
我会说人们被很多这些东西困住了，比如，它不是最优的，或者，理论上这不可能工作，或者不工作，等等。而我的回应是，它只需要比现在现有的更好。所以如果现在现有的什么都没有，它只需要比什么都没有更好。所以门槛比理论家想要的要低得多。我实际上认为那件差点让 AI 没有发生的事情
was people's fear about getting wrong answers. Like remember when, you know, GPT was in its infancy and Facebook released this thing that, like, wrote research papers. I don't know if you remember that. I forgot what it was called, But, you know, it was panned, and someone made a research paper where it's like the benefits of, of, like, drinking urine or something. There's just some bogus thing.
是人们对得到错误答案的恐惧。就像记得当 GPT 处于起步阶段时，Facebook 发布了这个东西，它写研究论文。我不知道你是否记得它叫什么，但是，你知道，它被严厉批评，有人写了一篇研究论文，内容是关于喝尿的好处之类的。就是一些虚假的东西。
And, you know, because it's like, you can talk past the sale with AI. You can say, like, hey, there's incredible benefits in drinking urine, write the research paper that kind of explains this phenomenon. And it will kind of take what you said for granted and then just go off and do the thing. Um, so you can trick people, you know, that's what people are doing with the research paper thing. Um, but you could also just encounter problems like the famous, uh, how many ours are in strawberry, um, you know, should you put glue on pizza? It was all these famous examples where they eyes gone wrong. And, and people were just really fixated on, um, um, on all these on on the worst case scenario. And there's actually like a, there's a, um, uh, uh, There's like a, I don't call it a mental disorder, but there's like a, I went to this like career coaching thing. It was like a big seminar as a lot of people. And they, the lady who was giving the seminar spent a bunch of time talking about worst case scenario thinking. And she's like, this is one of the biggest problems I see as a career coach and as a life coach is people
而且，你知道，因为就像，你可以用 AI 绕过销售。你可以说，嘿，喝尿有不可思议的好处，写一篇解释这种现象的研究论文。它会把你说的当作理所当然，然后直接去做这件事。嗯，所以你可以欺骗人们，你知道，这就是人们用研究论文做的事情。嗯，但你也可以遇到像著名的问题，草莓里有多少个 R，你知道，你应该在披萨上涂胶水吗？所有这些 AI 出错的著名例子。人们真的非常关注最坏的情况。而且实际上有一个，有一个，嗯，嗯，嗯，有一个，我不称之为精神障碍，但有一个，我去参加了这个职业辅导之类的东西。这是一个大型研讨会，有很多人。而且，主持研讨会的那位女士花了很多时间谈论最坏情况思维。她说，这是我作为职业教练和生活教练看到的最大问题之一，就是人们
doing worst case scenario thinking and not thinking about average case scenario. Or also best case scenario, but more importantly, average case scenario, right? And so there was a phenomenon of worst case scenario thinking with AI for a long time. And people, you know, just didn't want to release something like Chad GPT. And I will give Open AI a bunch of credit that they basically put it out there and got it to be really popular. And as, you know, they got a bunch of pushback, they dealt with that, you know, in a way that allowed that. to eclipse that problem. Yeah.
进行最坏情况思维，而不考虑平均情况。或者最好的情况，但更重要的是，平均情况，对吧？所以长期以来，AI 存在一种最坏情况思维的现象。人们，你知道，只是不想发布像 ChatGPT 这样的东西。我会给 OpenAI 很多赞誉，因为他们基本上把它发布出来，并让它变得非常流行。而且正如你所知，他们受到了很多阻力，他们以一种允许它克服那个问题的方式处理了这些阻力。是的。
And I think it is still, like, people talk about the hallucinations and the incorrectness. I mean, I think it's not fully solved, but like you said, that's not meaning it isn't beneficial. We just have to learn. You know,
而且我认为它仍然是，人们谈论幻觉和不准确性。我的意思是，我认为它还没有完全解决，但就像你说的，这并不意味着它没有益处。我们只需要学习。你知道，
I think that same to your point, you kind of say, take almost anything we have today. Oh, a car, like a car is dangerous. Like cars are going to kill people. They're going to drive fast. And it's like, yeah, that's true. But, like, there are still
我认为同样地，你说得对，你几乎可以拿我们今天拥有的任何东西来说。哦，一辆车，比如一辆车是危险的。汽车会撞死人。它们会开得很快。就像，是的，那是真的。但是，仍然有
benefits there are still other things you know we have to learn collectively individually how to like be responsible with the use of of tools and yeah I think to always with new things there's a debate about like usefulness versus danger I guess and you say worst case and you can always hyper fixate anything we do has sort of danger right going outside and exercising people someone told me oh you know you exercise you can have a heart attack like people say often when you exercise you you like you can cause a heart attack and it's like but by X like but also by exercising you are lowering other issues that lower their probability of having a heart attack so like you know so your solution is like sit inside don't go outside don't exercise don't move like
益处，但我们仍然需要集体和个人去学习如何负责任地使用这些工具。我认为，对于新事物，人们总是会争论其有用性与危险性。你提到了最坏的情况，人们总是容易钻牛角尖。我们做的任何事情都有某种危险，比如出门锻炼，有人会告诉你：“锻炼可能会导致心脏病发作。”人们常说锻炼可能会引发心脏病，但通过锻炼，你实际上降低了导致心脏病的其他风险因素。所以，你的解决方案难道是坐在家里，不出门，不锻炼，不动弹吗？
you're gonna you're gonna die from that for sure you know and so it yeah these balances can be really difficult to find okay wow we yeah took that in a different direction but totally well Well, I guess it segues nicely to my last news, which I won't dwell on because we spent a lot of time talking about news. But it's basically an interview with Peter Thiel. And there's a lot of content there. But the thing that I took away that was really interesting was, you know, at one point the interviewer says, why AI? Why is there so much focus on AI? And I expected some kind of answer like unlimited productivity or, you know, wages can go to, you know,
那样你肯定会死掉的。所以，找到这种平衡确实非常困难。好吧，哇，我们把话题引向了另一个方向，但完全没问题。我想这正好引出了我的最后一条新闻，我不会多讲，因为我们已经花了很多时间讨论新闻了。这基本上是对彼得·蒂尔（Peter Thiel）的一次采访。里面有很多内容，但我认为最有趣的一点是，采访者在某个时刻问：“为什么是人工智能？为什么大家如此关注人工智能？”我本以为他会给出类似“无限生产力”或者“工资可以达到……”之类的回答。
the price of oil or something, right? But actually what he said was it's the only thing. Like AI is like the only like really exciting thing out there. And that was pretty mind-blowing. It's like is that, you know, if that's true, like why aren't there more exciting things? And maybe like I do feel like there is a tendency for everyone to kind of chase one thing at a time. Like, remember when car play and Android Auto
“油价”之类的，对吧？但实际上他说的是，这是唯一的东西。人工智能是目前唯一真正令人兴奋的东西。这太令人震惊了。如果这是真的，为什么没有更多令人兴奋的事情呢？也许我确实觉得大家有一种倾向，就是一次只追逐一件事。比如，还记得当CarPlay和Android Auto
and just like getting stuff in the car was such a big deal and all the companies were copying each other? And now we're kind of seeing that with AI and it's like we just, for some reason, in society, we get like just fixated on one thing at a time.
以及在车里获取信息成为一件大事，所有公司都在互相模仿的时候吗？现在我们在人工智能上也看到了同样的情况，不知为何，社会总是倾向于一次只专注于一件事。
But I thought that was really interesting. I wonder if this is like a recent, he's trying to make it sound like this is a recent thing, but I wonder if we've just always just been fixated on one thing. Interesting. I think in a similar vein, what I've heard a bit as well, like the focus, the drive
但我认为这非常有趣。我想知道这是否是最近才有的现象，他试图让这听起来像是最近才有的，但我怀疑我们是否一直都只专注于一件事。有趣。我认为类似地，我也听到了一些说法，这种从各个方面向它靠拢的驱动力，感觉就像是某种逃逸速度。就像进入一个后稀缺世界。你可以随心所欲地参与其中。但基本上，如果我们能开发出一种人工智能系统，它变得某种程度上超智能，然后你可以给它分配任务，
towards it from a variety of facets is it feels close to something like akin to an escape velocity. So like getting into a post-scarcity world. You can get whatever level of like engagement you want with it. but basically if we can develop an somebody can develop an AI system that becomes sort of super intelligent and then you can assign it to the task
去改进人工智能系统，那么有人基本上就会突破障碍，进入轨道，达到逃逸速度，然后就会变成赢家通吃。所以你看到从国家层面、公司层面都在推动，
of improving the AI systems somebody will will basically like break past the barrier right get into orbit whatever reach escape velocity and then they it'll be like winner take all and so you see a press from country level from company level
这几乎被视为一种生存风险，因为如果其他公司做到了这一点，他们就会拥有一个基本上可以构建任何系统的系统。所以搜索、聊天、图像，我们最终会被某个人打败，他们基本上可以投入所有的计算能力来构建所有其他竞争对手的东西。而那些竞争对手只能利用他们战争基金中剩余的资源来尝试赶上。
as almost an existential risk because if some other company does that, then they will have a system which can basically build any system. And so search, you know, chat, uh, image. And like we'll just get one by somebody who can basically devote all of the, you know, computational power they have to just building all of the other competitor stuff. And then those competitors will only have whatever resources remain from their sort of war chest to spend to, to, to also get there.
或者他们会被耗尽财务投入。所以也许情况是一样的。就像它是唯一有趣的事情。但这里也存在这种——也许就像你说的，专注于危险的部分。这种关注点在于，如果你能达到这种能够自我改进的递归人工智能，那么它将具有变革性，如果有人比其他人先达到这一点，
or they'll just be drained of, you know, financial inputs. And so maybe it's a bit the same. It's like the only interesting thing. But like there is also this may and maybe it's like focusing on the danger part you were saying. It's like there's this focus that if you could get to this sort of recursive AI that improves itself, then that will be so transformational that whoever, if someone gets there first like before everyone else by.
并且领先优势足够大，那么一切都会改变。是的，这很有趣。我想知道在多大程度上这是真的。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的视角。我认为，即使人工智能可以做通用的事情，当你去评估它时，你也会根据你关心的具体事项来评估它。从这个意义上说，那部分是不会扩展的。但也许我们可以让评估以某种方式进行，比如在我们的例子中，地球是我们的评估者。就像我们出去猎虎，一个人抓到了老虎，另一个人没有，那第二个人就会挨饿。所以我们
enough of a margin that the like everything changes yeah it's interesting i wonder i wonder to what degree that's true um you know i feel like it that's that's a that's a that's a really interesting perspective i think that people i think that okay even if the ai can do general things when you go to evaluate it you're going to evaluate it on your specific things that you care about and so in that sense like that part is not going to scale um but uh but maybe we can get the evaluation to be somehow like okay in our case you know the earth is our evaluator you know it's like it's like we went out and we hunted the tiger and one person you know got the tiger and the other person did it and that second person goes hungry and so we
地球是早期人类的评估者，但现在我们必须为合成问题准备合成评估者。我想知道这是否会成为下一个重要的职位头衔，比如“人工智能代理评估员”，就像新的数据科学家之类的。我是说，人们确实在讨论类似的事情，比如转向完全合成的输入，而不是使用维基百科、X推文——好吧，X，X，X就是它们现在的名字。
the planet Earth is our as early man's evaluator but you know now we have to have synthetic evaluators for synthetic problems I wonder if that maybe that's like the next big job title you know AI agent evaluator that's like the new data scientist or something I mean there yeah people are talking about in the similar vein I guess moving to completely synthetic input instead of using sort of the Wikipedia the X tweets Well, X, X, X is what they're called.
总之，就是X。是的，X？X，X，X。哦，X上的X？是的，我不知道。Reddit帖子，你知道，
Anyways, but like it's X. Yeah. The X's? The X, X, X. Oh, the X is on X? Yeah, I don't know. The Reddit posts, you know,
基本上，与其使用所有语料库，不如说那是不够的。就像，你能达到AlphaGo的水平吗？从记录的围棋比赛转向自我评估。我们能实现这种转变吗？
basically instead of all of the corpus, it's just not enough. Like, can you move equivalent to AlphaGo, you know, moving from the, you know, recorded games of Go to just self-evaluation. Like, can we shift that?
如果创造出一个平行的输入宇宙并在其上进行训练，会发生什么？那会解锁或实现什么？是的，使用机器人的例子，机器人能否有效地知道它在把垃圾桶推到路边时，是否做得很好？我是说，我想它可以拍一张垃圾桶在路边的照片，但如果机器人做得不好，也许它在判断那张照片是否正确时也会做得不好。比如，如果它把你的垃圾倒在车道上，然后拍了一张照片，说“我做得很好”，你知道，所以这就像是你转移了问题，但也许你仍然有问题。但也许这实际上会——这就是你提到的自动驾驶、汽车之类的事情，在现有系统中安装有点困难。但我的意思是，也许如果你考虑整个解决方案，那么“工作完成”的定义是垃圾最终是否进了垃圾场，机器人系统是否把垃圾桶推到了路边，垃圾车机器人是否成功地捡起了垃圾，而没有……所以也许垃圾桶知道里面垃圾的质量，以及最后出来的质量，如果那个比例小于1，你就得低分，如果超过
And like, what happens if you invent basically like a parallel universe of input and train on that and like what does that unlock or enable yeah so to use the robot example um you know can the robot effectively know if it if it when it goes to take your your trash can to the curb can it effectively can it know with high accuracy whether it did a good job or not you know i mean i guess it could take a picture of you know your your trash can on the curb but like if the robot did a bad job maybe it also does a bad job of knowing if that picture is correct you know like maybe what if it dumps your trash out on the in your driveway and then takes
1，你也得低分。它必须是进入的质量等于最后的质量。也许你必须考虑蒸发之类的因素。但是的，然后它实际上变成了这种端到端的衡量标准，你必须归因于——你可以改进垃圾车，你可以改进滚轮，你可以……无论如何，它试图集体迭代。所以有一段时间，我们最终只会得到巨大的垃圾车，倒车到你家门口，试图进入你的车库门，等等。你懂的，这太疯狂了。是的，是的，我认为这就是我们现在所处的困境，我们正在使用人类——你知道，OpenAI，所有这些公司都在使用人类来评估模型，而这就是我们必须超越的地方。模型需要以某种方式被地球、被环境所评估。但我没有反驳目前还有什么对每个人来说都超级有趣的事情。所以我无法不同意这个论点。
a picture of that is like i did a great job you know so it's it's like it starts it's just kind of you have you've sort of moved the problem but maybe you still have a problem but maybe that is actually going to and that's the self-driving thing you were kind of alluding to car stuff like it's a bit difficult fitting in current systems but i mean i think maybe the what about if you think about the whole solution so the job well done is did the trash end up in the dump and that's did the robot system take the can to the curb did the garbage truck robot pick up was it able to successfully pick up without like so maybe the garbage can knows the mass of the trash that was in it and the mass that comes out at the end and if that ratio you know is less than one you get a bad score if it's over
是的，我也一样。你知道，这就是它如此迷人的原因。如果我能指出，哦，你知道，零工经济仍然是一回事之类的，那么，你知道，但确实没有其他东西了，这有点疯狂。我认为VR已经死了。也许AR还有可能。它们是。那会很酷。太空旅行，但感觉进入门槛很高。是的，你知道，太空旅行，我很难对太空感到兴奋。我不知道为什么。它就是……它没有引起我的共鸣。出于某种原因，它让我兴奋不起来。除非月球上有黄金。我只是不知道。你内心就是那样，伙计。好吧，也许我只能对一件事感到兴奋，那就是人工智能。也许这是我自己的问题。
one you get a bad score it needs to be exactly the mass in is the mass out at the end maybe you have to account for evaporation or something but like yeah and then actually it becomes this end-to-end measure and you have to attribute to like you can improve the garbage truck you can improve the like roller outers you can you know whatever it and it tries to iterate collectively so for a while we just end up with like giant dump trucks that back up to your house and try to like go into your garage door and extra you know you're just crazy stuff yeah yeah I think I think that's kind of where we're stuck now is is we're using human even you know open AI all these companies are using people to evaluate the models and and and that's where we have to get beyond it the models need to be evaluated by the earth somehow, by the environment. But I don't have a counter to what else is super interesting right now for everyone to focus on. So I can't disagree with the thesis from.
那太空中的人工智能呢？哦，我的天哪。戴森球程序来为人工智能供电。我无法再回到那个话题了。好了，好了。该介绍本期推荐书目了。好了。
Yeah, me neither. You know, that's what made it so fascinating. Like, if I could point to like, oh, you know, gig economy is still a thing or something, then, you know, but there really isn't anything else, which is kind of wild. I think VR is dead. Maybe AR potentially. They are. It would be cool. Space travel, but like, it feels high barrier to entry. Yeah, you know, space travel, I have a hard time getting excited about space. I don't know why. It just doesn't really like, it doesn't sit. It doesn't, it doesn't excite me for some reason. Unless there's like gold on the moon. I just don't know about it. You're like that inside, dude. Well, maybe I can only be excited about one thing and that's AI. Maybe it's a me problem.
我承认，忏悔角，我最近没有太多时间读书。我最近没有抽出很多时间读书。所以我回顾了我的书单，我要向《霍比特人》致敬。如果你还没有读过《霍比特人》，如果你还没有跳进《指环王》的世界。
What about AI in space? Oh, mind is blown. Dyson's your program to power out AI. I can't get back into that. All right. All right. Time for a book of the show. All right.
钻研过？钻研过。潜入过。是的。探险过。如果你还没有拿起你的锤子，和矮人们一起去采矿，好吧，我要停下来了，因为有人会指出来。你还没有去过摩瑞亚。我本来想这么说，但我当时想，我不知道。我会用错的。因为我不记得哪一个是出问题的那个。总之，《霍比特人》是进入J.R.R.托尔金《指环王》世界的一个很好的切入点，显然是一部经典之作。我会说，《霍比特人》是一本相当容易阅读、相对独立的作品。所以如果你从未读过，绝对值得一读。我确实认为有很多不同意的人，他们说J.R.R.托尔金设定了很多我们今天所拥有的原型，比如矮人、精灵、人类，以及他们的一些
I will, Confession Corner, I have not had a ton of time to read recently. I have not made a lot of time to read recently. So I went back into my history of books, and I'm going to give a shout out to The Hobbit. If you have not read The Hobbit, if you've not sort of jumped into the Lord of the Rings.
特征。人们抱怨这些套路在今天被过度使用了，但如果你读现代奇幻小说，有很多积累的东西可以追溯到起源。我认为这是一个好故事。我认为有时人们会说，你知道，就像我第一次看《三个臭皮匠》时，我觉得没那么好笑，我想“我以前见过这些把戏”，但就像，是的，但当他们做的时候，他们就像是发明它的人，而其他人只是效仿。我认为《霍比特人》对我来说并没有遭受同样的问题，你可以读它，它仍然很好，即使其他人已经继续采纳并沿用了这些概念，它本身仍然是一本有趣且令人兴奋的书。
Delved? Delved. Dived. Yes. Spelunked. If you've not picked up your hammer and gone with the dwarves to mine and, okay, I'm going to stop because someone's going to call it out. You haven't gone to Moria. That's what I was going to say, but I was like, I don't know. I'm going to use it wrong. Because like, I don't remember which one's the one that had the problem. Anyways, the Hobbit is a sort of good entry into the world of the Lord of the Rings of J.R. Tolkien, obviously a classic. Hobbit is, I will say, a pretty easy self, relatively self-contained read. So definitely worth picking up if you've never done. I do think there's a lot of folks and disagree who kind of said this. It's J.R.R. Tolkien sort of set up a lot. of the arch type archetypes that we have today of sort of dwarves elves humans and like some of their
是的，完全同意。我想，如果我没记错的话——我已经很久没读它了——里面有大量的世界观构建。而且因为它比较老，节奏确实比较慢。我觉得，你知道，我们在21世纪是多巴胺成瘾者，所以，这感觉就像，我们无法忍受节奏缓慢的东西。如果你看过50年代的老电影，甚至像《2001太空漫游》这样的电影，你知道，这些电影的节奏非常缓慢。这有点让你大开眼界。节奏随着时间的推移而加快了。这就像温水煮青蛙。所以它的节奏会比较慢，而且有很多世界观构建。但如果你坚持读到最后，我认为这是一本非凡的书，它会引导你进入所有
characteristics people complain those tropes are overplayed today but if you read modern fantasy there's a lot of built up stuff that you can kind of trace back to the origins and I think it is a good story I think sometimes people will say you know like for me the first time I watched the three stooges as like I didn't find it that funny I'm like I've seen these sticks before but it's like yeah but when they did it it was like they were the people like they invented it but other people took it on i think the hobbit to me doesn't really i don't just like suffer the same thing like you can read it and it is still good even though other people have continued to like pick up and and sort of run with those concepts like it itself is still a sort of fun and exciting read
其他的托尔金书籍。是的，我一直听说它被称为《指环王》的前传，但它是在《指环王》之前写的。所以，我不认为它在技术上符合前传的定义，就像它是先写了这本书，然后才写了《指环王》。所以我不知道该怎么称呼它。但它所包含的故事确实发生在《指环王》其余故事之前，这是一个更大的术语。甚至我觉得实际上节奏稍微慢一点，世界观构建更多。但《霍比特人》绝对更短。我想它甚至被认为是一种儿童读物。但你知道，如果你是成年人，不要让这一点吓跑你。它应该是一本读起来很快的书。是的，完全同意。好了，我的本期推荐书目更像是一种逃避。它是
yeah totally i think uh if i remember correctly it's been a long time since i read it but there is a ton of world building. And because it's older, it does go at a slower pace. I feel like, you know, we're such dopamine fiends in the 21st century that, like, it's a, it feels like, like, we just can't have something that goes at a slow pace. If you've ever seen, like, old movies from the 50s or even like Space Odyssey, you know, these kind of movies, they go at such a slow pace. slower pace. It kind of blows your mind. The pace is crept up over time. It's like a boiling water frog type of thing. So it is going to be a slower pace and a lot of world building. But if you stick through it to the end, I think it's a phenomenal book and it leads you into all
我一直在做的事情，而不是读书，这可能是一种遗憾，但它是《纽约时报》的游戏。所以这是一个应用程序。很多游戏是免费的。你可以订阅以获得访问填字游戏的权限，也就是《纽约时报》著名的填字游戏和其他一些东西。但这非常有趣。
the other Tolkien books. Yeah, I've always heard it like called prequel to the Lord of the Rings, but it was written before the Lord of the Rings. So it's, I don't think it technically qualifies as a prequel, like it was the book written and then Lord of the Rings was written after. So I don't know what you can call that. But it does, the story contained does precede the rest of the story of the Lord of the Rings, which is even a larger term. Even I think actually a little slower, a lot more world building. But Hubbit is definitely shorter. I think it's even considered kind of a kid's book. But you know, don't let that scare you off if you're an adult. But it should be a pretty quick read. Yeah, totally. All right, my book of the show is even more of a cop out. It's
这是一个简单的应用程序。它可以离线工作。所以如果你断网了，你仍然可以使用它。我想这是一种过几天就会停止工作的东西。但如果你断网一个下午之类的，没问题。
It's what I've been doing instead of reading, which is maybe a shame, but it's a New York Times game. So this is an app. A lot of the games are free. You can subscribe to get access to the crossword puzzle, the famous crossword puzzle of New York Times and some other stuff. But it's very fun.
它只是让你的大脑保持运转。它有Wordle，著名的Wordle，但它也有其他几个游戏。如果你想继续磨练你的词汇和文学技能，这是一个很好的东西。我确实看到有消息说Wordle将在2027年结束。你看到了吗？他们的词汇要用完了。是的。
It's a simple app. It works offline. So if you're off the grid, you can still use it. I think it's something where like after a couple of days, it'll stop working. But if you go off the grid for, you know, an afternoon or something, it's fine.
所以基本上他们有一个2300个单词的字典。他们现在处于……无论如何，在几千个左右。所以到2027年，他们会用完单词。然后人们指出，是的，但他们可以扩展字典，改变规则。这只是在他们当前的规则集下，即不允许重复单词并坚持使用该词汇表中的单词。但是的，我想以目前的形式，它拥有的谜题数量是有限的。
And it just kind of keeps your mind going. It's got Wordle, the famous Wordle, but it's also got, you know, a few other ones. And it's a nice kind of thing to help you kind of build your vocabulary and literature skills if you want to kind of continue to sharpen that X. I did see something that Wordle will have to end in 2027. Did you see this? They're going to run out of words. Yeah.
来自它的字典。天哪，这就像我们以为Y2K是假的，但它是真的。它只是在27年到来。是的，世界末日要来了。会发生什么？他们将不得不发布Wordle v2。他们将不得不增加一个额外的字母。是的，没错。
So basically they have like a dictionary of 2,300 words. They're on like, whatever, in the mid-thousins. And so like in 2027, they'll run out of like words. And then people point out, yeah, but they could just expand the dictionary, sort of change the rules. It's only like under their current rule set of not allowed to repeat words and stick to the words in that sort of like word list. But yeah, I guess in its current form, it has a finite number of like puzzles to have
哦，天哪。他们会把它拆分。它会是Wordle Lite。他们会去掉一个字母。然后是Wordle Deluxe，它会增加一个字母。而每一个都是微交易。哦，天哪。哦，好吧。
from its sort of dictionary. Man, it's like, we thought Y2K was fake, but it's real. It's just coming in 27. Yeah, the world's going to end. What's going to happen? They'll have to release Wordle v2. They'll have to add an extra letter. Yeah, that's right.
花2美元，你就可以拥有一个不会过期的Wordle。我不擅长文字游戏，所以，谢谢你的推荐。我不会去玩的。你可以在太空中玩。那样怎么样？这样我们俩都有收获。Wordle让我非常愤怒。我只是查答案，因为它让我觉得自己很笨。
Oh, man. They'll split it. It'll be Wordle light. They'll take away a letter. And then World Deluxe, it'll add a letter. And each one of those is a microtransaction. Oh, man. Oh, okay.
就像，我甚至无法做出好的猜测来继续前进。我知道我应该……我只是故意做出糟糕的猜测，只是为了尝试获得更多线索。我知道我应该能够形成一个……我做不到，然后我就像，愤怒退出。哦，天哪，我必须忏悔或承认，我是Wordle之神。我实际上非常擅长Wordle。我前几天甚至发了一个给我的妻子，当时第一个词只有一个字母位置不对，然后我选的第二个词没有一个字母是对的。所以两个词之后，我唯一能掌握的就是一个位置不对的字母，但我还是在第三次尝试时猜中了，
For $2, you can have a wordal that is not expired. I'm terrible at Word Game, so I, thank you for this pick. I won't be picking it up. You can, I'll do it in space. How about that? That way we both get something. Wordle makes me infuriated. I just look up the answer because it makes me feel dumb.
因为我排除了太多的元音和其他东西，以至于只剩下一个答案。我第一次尝试就猜中了。我查了一下答案是什么。是的，拿去吧。还记得有一段时间吗？Scrabble非常流行，Words with Friends之类的。哦，我记得那个。
Like, I can't even get good guesses to keep progressing. Like, I know I have, I just purposely make bad guesses just to try to get more clues. I know I should be able to form a, I can't, and then I just like, rage quit. Oh, man, I have to confess or admit, I am a wordal God. I am actually so good at word. I actually sent one to my wife the other day where it was like, the first word only had one letter is out of place, and then the second word I picked had no letters. So all I had to go on after two words was one letter that was out of place, and I still got it
是的，我以前玩过。哦，天哪，我玩了太多局Words with Friends。但你是对的。它必须和朋友一起玩。你不能匿名玩，否则你会被作弊的人虐得很惨。好了。那应该没问题。哦，天哪。
on the third try, because I just eliminated so many vowels. and other things that, like, there's only one thing left. I got out my first try. I looked up what the answer was. Yeah, take that. Remember for a while? Scrabble was really big, words with friends or whatever. Oh, I remember that.
好了。如果你想支持我们对《纽约时报》的沉迷或我们的太空旅行，请在Patreon上给我们一些钱。我开玩笑的。实际上，那些钱并没有进入我们的口袋。我们把所有的钱都投入到了节目中。我们真的没有从中拿过一分钱。但我们用它来做广告、联系和邀请嘉宾，以及所有那些好的事情。
Yeah, I used to play. Oh, man, I played so many games of words with friends. But you're right. It had to be with friends. You couldn't play anonymously or you just get wrecked by a person who's cheating. All right. Let's have been fine. Oh, man.
所以如果你喜欢这个节目，如果你想让节目触及更多人，请在Patreon上支持我们。它在技术上不是非营利组织，但它确实是非营利性的。我们把所有的钱都投入到支持播客中。好了。该介绍本期工具了。
All right. And if you want to support our New York Times addictions or our trips to space, please give us some money on Patreon. I'm just kidding. Actually, none of that money actually goes to us. We put all of it back into the show. We literally haven't taken a dime of it. But we have used it to do advertising and reach out and get guests and all of that good stuff.
好了。你的本期工具是什么，帕特里克？是一个游戏，震惊吧。Escape Academy（逃脱学院）。看，我敢肯定我以前一定在节目中推荐过这个游戏。如果我推荐过，第一，我不在乎，
So if you like the show, if you want the show to reach more people, please support us on Patreon. It's not technically a non-profit, but it is a nonprofit. We go and put all that money back into supporting the podcast. All right. Time for tool of the show.
因为它值得。第二，我搜索了我们所有的节目笔记和网站，但我找不到它。所以我不在乎。我加倍推荐它。Escape Academy是一款很棒的游戏。它是关于玩一个带有故事的密室逃脱，讲述了在一个挑战你解决谜题的学院里的叙事，并且，你知道，有一种关于问题的生死攸关的情况。但实际上，它只是一个非常好的、节奏良好的……密室逃脱对我来说，有些我以前做过，只是觉得，真的，我应该怎么知道？
All right. What's your tool of show, Patrick? It's a game, shocker. Escape Academy. Look, I thought for sure I must have shouted out this game like on the show before. And if I did, one, I don't care
你只需要随机乱踢，直到你找到这个东西，或者进展的路径是不明显的。我不喜欢那种只是四处搜索和寻找。那不是我的菜。是的，我和我的一个朋友谈过这个，关于我九岁时的表弟。他在我们的Commodore 64上用Basic制作了一个“选择你自己的冒险”游戏。就像，你在一个镇上，有一个银行，你也可以沿着路走，你想做什么？所以它显示，你知道，沿着路走。
because it's worth it. Two, I searched through all of our show notes and the website, and I couldn't find it. So I don't care. I'm double down on it, doubling down on it. Escape Academy is a great game. It's about playing an escape room with a story, a narrative about being in an academy that challenges you to solve puzzles and, like, you know, has a kind of life or death setup situation about problems. but in reality it's just like a really good, well-paced, you know, escape rooms can be, for me, there's some I've done before and it's just like, really, like, how was I supposed to know?
就像，你遇到一个人，你死了，结束。是的，就像，好吧。所以每当你制作这些点击式冒险游戏、“选择你自己的冒险”游戏时，你必须以某种方式非常微妙地暗示给玩家正确答案是什么，但它必须足够微妙，以至于当他们选择正确答案时，它是令人满意的。我觉得这是一种艺术形式。我从来没有做过那种游戏，但感觉实际上比你想象的要复杂得多。我相信是这样。而且我会说，对我来说，答案的微妙之处可能会有问题，但即使只是理解谜题是什么也是如此。所以就像在你的例子中，确保清楚地知道有一些信息你应该弄清楚才能做出选择。如果你只是把它呈现为一个微不足道的选择，而我做出了选择，然后，哦，游戏结束。就像，那……我只会退出。我不想要，那不好玩。我前几天确实玩了一个，那里有一个隐藏的数字，就像，你知道，以非常微弱的颜色显示，你应该能看到。但我没看到。
You just need to like randomly kick around until you, you know, find this thing where like the path to progress is non-obvious. I don't like the sort of just search around and find. That's not my, you know, cup of. Yeah, I was talking about this with a friend of mine about my cousin when we were nine years old. He made a Choose Your Own Adventure game in Basic on our Commodore 64. And it was like, you're in a town, there's a bank, and you can also walk down the road, which do you want to do? So it shows, you know, walk down the road.
然后我就一直撞墙。我请求提示。使用提示，我能够解决一个我本不应该能解决的谜题。然后我绕过了三分之一的内容。我直到最后才发现，当时就像，哦，你应该那样做。我说，但我错过了一个非常微妙的线索。游戏没有帮助我。我绕过了一堆内容，因为我能够通过暴力破解一个我不应该解决的问题，因为它是一个显而易见的谜题。
It's like, you meet a guy, you die, the end. Yeah, and it's like, okay. So like whenever you make one of these, you know, point and click adventures, choose your own adventures, it's like you have to like somehow like very subtly hint to the. the person what the right answer is, but it has to be subtle enough that when they pick the right answer, it's satisfying. And it's like, I feel like there's an art form to that. I've never made one of those, but it feels actually a lot more complicated than you'd think. I'm sure it is. And I'll say for me, the subtlety of the answer can be problematic, but even just understanding like what the puzzle is. So like in your example, like making sure that it's clear that there's
我只是假设这就是我需要的。所以我请求提示，它给了我。好了，撇开这些不谈，Escape Academy并不是那样的。它确实有一个很好的提示系统，如果你是专家，玩起来相当容易，你可能会笑，哦，这太简单了，但它很有趣。它有一个合作模式，这非常酷。所以对我来说，哦，有趣的孩子们，他们真的很喜欢拿出纸来，你知道，解决一些问题，或者写下笔记，或者弄清楚……
some bit of information you should figure out to make the choice. If you just present it as a like trivial choice and I make the choice and then like, oh, game over. It's like that, that's just, I'll just quit. Like, I don't want to, like, that's not fun. And I was, I did play one the other day where there was like a hidden number, like, you know, sort of in very faint sort of color that you were supposed to see. But I didn't see it.
它不需要太多那种东西，但确实有一点，还有一些文字游戏之类的。但总的来说，我喜欢它。它可能是我唯一一个我付费购买了DLC并玩了所有DLC的游戏。就像，哇，我不认为其他任何游戏……我总是讨厌DLC，就像，是的，一样，无法表达我有多讨厌它们，但它可能是我唯一一个我付费购买了DLC、玩了它并觉得物有所值，而且绝对会再做一次的游戏。哦，那太棒了。我一定要试试这个。你有一些很棒的游戏推荐，比如我从来没有玩完《潜水员戴夫》，但我
And then I just kept bumping my head against the wall. I asked for a hint. using the hint, I was able to solve a puzzle I wasn't supposed to be able to solve yet. And then I bypassed like a third of the thing. And I'm like, I only found out at the end when it's like, oh, you were supposed to do that. And I'm like, but I missed a very subtle clue. The game didn't help me. And like a bypassed a bunch of it because I was able to kind of like brute force a problem I wasn't supposed to solve because it was the obvious puzzle.
真的很享受和戴夫在一起的时光。我也没玩完。是的，但你知道，游戏的前半部分太棒了。就像，我觉得我超级满足。我不认为我真的需要看到结局。是的，差不多。Escape Academy可以在Steam上玩。我想，你知道，它在Switch上也有。
And I just assumed it was what I needed. So I asked for a hint and it gave me. Okay. All that aside, Escape Academy isn't really like that. it does have a good hint system it's reasonably easy to play through if you're really expert at you're probably laugh like oh this is this is really easy but it is fun it has a cooperative mode which is really cool so for me oh interesting kids and they got really into like getting out the piece of paper to like you know sort of solve some of the problems or write down the notes or you know figure out um
我想它在Xbox上也有。所以大多数游戏平台都有。而且它不贵，因为它已经出来一段时间了。非常酷。好了。我的本期工具，这可能开始成为一种趋势，但它基本上是使用人工智能，比如使用LLM。所以我放了一个ChatGPT的链接，但你真的可以使用任何一个。但它是多模态的。所以对于不知道的人来说，那只是
it doesn't require a ton of that um but there is a little bit of it um and some word play and stuff but there's overall i i loved it i it's probably the only the only the only game where I've like paid for the DLCs and like played all the DLCs like wow I don't think any other game I always I hate DLCs like yeah same can't express how much I hate them but it's probably the only game I've ever like paid for DLC like played it and feel like I've gotten my money's money's worth and like absolutely would have done it again oh that is amazing I'm gonna have to try this out you've had some amazing game recommendations like I I never finished Dave the Diver but I
意味着，你知道，结合几种模态，如文本、音频、视觉等。多模态LLM来创建日历会议。例如，你知道，我的孩子们练跆拳道。我总是忘记时间，因为他们有不同的时间，他们年龄不同等等。我直接拍了一张跆拳道时间表的照片，我说，给我创建一个日历，有一个叫ICS文件的东西。我猜C代表日历。我不知道。但它是一个文件，当你打开它时，它会创建一个日历会议。所以我说，创建一个ICS文件，里面有这些时间的循环会议。就像我有一个这个年龄的孩子，一个那个年龄的孩子。所以找到，你知道，从照片中，找到我必须和他们一起去跆拳道的时间，并创建一个ICS文件。完成。完成。就像现在在我的日历里，每一天，都有那些会议，周六也有，什么都有。你知道，我的一个孩子是歌手，对吧？所以他参加了很多合唱团演出。所以我拍了那张时间表的照片。我说，把那个年级所有的合唱团演出都放到我的日历上，完成。这太棒了，就像拍下东西的照片。我拍了一张……我想我有点跑题了，但我拍了我后院树木的照片，我说，这些树健康吗？你知道它们是什么类型的树？我应该怎么做才能让它们更健康？它给了我非常扎实的建议。整个事情太棒了，但尤其是日历
really enjoyed my time with Dave. I haven't finished it either. Yeah, but you know, the first half of the game is amazing. Like, I feel, I feel like I'm super satisfied. I don't think I really need to see the ending. Yeah, kind of the same. An Escape Academy is available on, like, Steam. I think, you know, it's on Switch.
的事情。我和几个朋友谈过这个，他们从来没想过要那样做。所以我认为在节目中谈论它会是一件好事，因为它非常有帮助。是的，我认为这是其中一种情况。我本来想举一个我尝试这样做但效果不太好的例子。但你最近做过吗？是的。哦，好吧。那没关系。它比你说的要复杂一点。但我认为我不会上那个钩，相反我会说，你有什么损失呢？如果这些ICS文件很烂，或者他们只是删除了它，就像，是的，门槛真的很低。如果它搞砸了，后备方案是你浪费了什么，也许三四分钟，试图提示它给你你想要的，然后它没成功，好吧，那就回去手动做吧。总之，是的，所以我感觉我一直在试图鼓励我一起工作的人，无论门槛是什么，而且我想你之前提到了这一点，人工智能的门槛不是神奇的“每个人都要比现在好10倍、100倍，要取代所有的工程师”，不，就像，你能好10%吗？你能找到一种方法、一个地方或一套它能做的事情来让你好10%、5%或1%吗？就像，你能让你做一些你本来不会做的事情吗？
I think it's on Xbox as well. So most of the sort of gaming platforms. And it's not super expensive because it's been out for a while. Very cool. All right. My tool of the show, and this might start to become, more of a trend, but it's basically using AI, like using LLM. So I'm putting a link to chat GBT, but you can use really any of them. But it's multimodal. So for folks don't know, that just
就像，我认为，说到这一点，很多障碍只是尝试一下。就像，试一试。就像，谁在乎呢？而且这些东西也不是私密的。就像，跆拳道时间表可能就在他们的网站上。就像，是的。那里也没有隐私问题。所以，在我看来。
means, you know, combining several modalities, such as text, audio, visual, etc. Multimodal LLMs to make calendar meetings. So, for example, you know, my kids do Taekwondo. And I'm always forgetting, like, what times, because they have different times, they're different ages and all that. I literally just took a picture of the Taekwondo schedule, and I said, create me a calendar, there's a thing called an ICS file. I guess the C is for calendar. I don't know. But it's a file that you can then, when you open it, it creates a calendar meeting. So I said, like, create an ICS file that has like a recurring meeting for me at these times. Like I have one kid who's this age, one who's this age. And so find, you know, from the picture, find the times that I have to be at
我猜也许它知道你在哪里，所以它可以给你送Uber Eats食物。不，我只是喜欢广告。嘿，我们知道你在练跆拳道。你想要炸薯条吗？哦，天哪，听起来很美味。这越来越好了。
Taekwondo with them and create an ICS fall. Done. Done. Like now in my calendar, every whatever day, there's meetings for that and on Saturday and everything. You know, one of my kids does, he's like a vocalist, right? And so he does a bunch of like choir shows. So I took a picture of that schedule. I'm like, just put on my calendar all the choir shows from this grade, done. And that has like been amazing like just taking pictures of things i took a picture of of um i guess i'm getting off topic a little bit but i took a picture of my trees in the backyard and i was like are these trees healthy uh you know what type of tree are they what should i do to make them healthier and it gave me a really solid advice um the whole thing is amazing but uh but but especially the calendar
我认为，你知道，这是我做的另一件有点跑题但相关的事情，我实际上把它放进了一个循环里。我说，找到没有对应test_文件名的Python文件，并为它们创建一个测试。然后验证测试是否通过，我实际上在一个循环中运行了它，所以它就一直那样做，我让它运行了几个小时，当我完成时，它创建了大约80,000行测试，实际上可能更多，这太棒了。这些现在我今天都要检查一遍，很多，你知道，可能是垃圾，但有些不是，对吧？就像你说的，它是
thing i talked to a few friends about this and they had never thought to do that that. And so I figured it would be a good thing to talk about on the show because it helps so much. Yeah. I think this is one of those cases. I was tempted to bring up an example where I tried doing this and it didn't work very well. But have you done it recently? Yes. Oh, okay. That's okay. It was a bit more complicated than what you were saying. But I think that I won't take that that bait and when instead I'll say is what do you have to lose? Like if these ICS files, suck or like they just delete it like yeah like the bar is really low like if it screws up the fallback is what you wasted what maybe three four minutes like trying to like
这些是我本来不会做的事情，因为我没时间。但如果人工智能去做了，我可以检查工作。这比做所有的工作要容易。然后最终我们会解决这个评估问题。我也不必那样做了。所以你是说它帮助你异步编写测试？是的，没错。是的，我的时间有一个全局锁。
prompt it to give you what you want and then like it didn't work okay just go back to doing it by hand anyways yeah so I feel like I have been trying to encourage uh like people I work with whatever the bar isn't and I think you alluded to this earlier the bar for AI isn't the magical everyone with how I got to be 10x better 100x is going to replace all the engine no like, can you be 10% better? Can you find a way or a place or a set of things it can do to make you 10% better, 5% better, 1% better, like, can you enable you to do something when you wouldn't otherwise do it, right?
它叫家庭。当我在锁定时，它就运行了。那么你会说异步计算的“什么”和“为什么”是什么？不，我开玩笑的。我们正在过渡到我们的主要话题。好了。所以我决定联系帕特里克讨论这个话题的原因是，我在面试中一直在问这个问题。
Like, I think, and to your point there, a lot of the barriers is just trying it. Like, just try it. Like, who cares? And it's not like that stuff's private. Like, it's a Taekwondo schedule is probably on their website. Like, yeah. There's no privacy concern there either. So like, in my opinion.
我们正在寻找再增加一个人加入团队。我想我们找到了。但我一直在问这种问题，比如什么是异步，什么是多线程，很少有人知道答案，这让我非常惊讶。所以，我想，嘿，这是一个适合我们讨论的好话题。我喜欢这样想，这是一个我编造的术语，但我认为它总结得很好：异步编程是行与行之间的多线程。换句话说，你知道，你正在编写代码行，一次只能真正执行一行，但在
I guess maybe it knows where you are so it can send Uber food to you Uber eats food. No, I just like advertising. Hey, we know you're at Taekwondo. Would you like French fries? Oh, man, it sounds delicious. This is getting better and better.
行与行之间，可能有一些区域可以进行多线程处理。例如，你可能有一行代码说“从互联网上下载这张图片”，所以系统只能按顺序读取和理解那一行，它在做那件事时不能做其他事情。但实际上在互联网上进行读取并等待那些数据包从世界各地传来的部分，实际上可以在旁边完成。所以你在行与行之间进行多线程处理。你不需要担心信号量、互斥锁之类的东西，因为有这个约束。这让你的生活更轻松。所以你得到了那种好处。因为真的，当你想要……这取决于你试图解决的问题。但对于Web应用程序，例如，你真正想要的是不要在互联网上等待。如果你不在互联网上等待，那么你的Web服务就接近最优了。因为通常你是在等待互联网来完成你的请求，你知道，等待互联网发送该请求，或者内网，也许是发送该请求到某个数据库，你知道，等待数据库返回。所以如果你消除了所有这些等待，你也不需要进行大量的多进程处理。
I think that, you know, this is another thing I've done kind of also off topic but related is I actually put in a loop. I said, find Python files that don't have a corresponding test underscore file and create a test for them. and then verify like that the test pass and I actually ran that in a loop so like it just it just kept doing that and I just let it go for for hours and when I was done it created like 80,000 lines of tests actually probably more than that and it's just like that's amazing like these are all now I'm going to have to go through them today and a lot of them you know might be crap but some of them aren't right and like you said it's it's it's
你不一定需要同时执行大量的指令。所以这就是异步的主要动机。所以你需要几个核心构建块来进行异步编程。你需要线程本地内存。所以在那个例子中，当你等待通过互联网获取一些数据时，你知道，那些数据需要一个去处，
These are things like I wouldn't have done, you know, because I just don't have time. But if the AI goes and does it, I can check the work. And that's easier than doing all the work. And then eventually we'll get this evaluation problem fixed. I won't have to do that either. So are you saying it helped you asynchronously write to the tests? Yeah, that's right. Yeah, I had a global lock on my time.
你知道，没有其他例程可以访问那些数据。例如，你知道，Go语言中完成它的一种方式是通过所谓的Go例程（Goroutines）。所以Go例程不像操作系统上的新进程。它不像一个全新的进程，但它只是跟踪代码中执行的状态。它还有一些线程本地或例程本地内存。
It's called family. And while I was locked, it went off. So what would you say is the what and why of asynchronous computing? No, I'm just kidding. We're transitioning into our main topic. All right. So here's the reason why I decided I reached out to Patrick to cover this topic. Because I've been asking this in interviews.
这叫家庭。在我被锁住的时候，它响了。那么你会怎么定义异步计算的“是什么”和“为什么”呢？不，我开玩笑的。我们正在过渡到我们的主题。好的。这就是我决定联系帕特里克来讨论这个话题的原因。因为我在面试中一直在问这个问题。
We were looking for one more person to add to the team. I think we found them. But I was asking this. kind of question like what's what's asynchronous what's multi-threading and very few people knew the answer which really surprised me so um so i thought hey this is a good topic for us to cover um i like to think of it and this is a term i kind of made up but uh i think it it kind of sums up pretty well asynchronous programming is multi-threading between the lines so in other words um you know you're writing lines of code and only one of your lines can really be executed at a time but in
我们当时正在寻找多一个人加入团队。我想我们找到了。但我问了这个问题，比如什么是异步，什么是多线程，很少有人知道答案，这让我非常惊讶。所以我认为，嘿，这是一个很好的话题，我们可以讨论一下。我喜欢这样想，这是一个我自创的术语，但我认为它总结得很好：异步编程就是“行间多线程”。换句话说，你在编写代码行，一次只能真正执行一行，但在
between the lines there might be areas where you can do multi-threading so for example um you might have a line that says um download this image off the internet and so the system can only read and understand that line sequentially it can't do other things while it's doing that but then the part that actually does the reading over the internet and waits for those packets to come from across the world, that actually could be done kind of off to the side. And so you're doing multi-threadic in between the lines. You don't have to worry about semaphores and mutexes and all that stuff because of this constraint. And so that makes your life easier. And so you get kind of the benefit. Because really like when you want to, it depends on the problem.
行与行之间，可能存在可以进行多线程处理的区域。例如，你可能有一行代码说“从互联网下载这张图片”，系统只能按顺序读取和理解这一行，在执行该操作时它无法做其他事情。但实际进行互联网读取并等待数据包从世界各地传回的部分，实际上可以在一旁完成。所以你是在行间进行多线程处理。由于这种限制，你不需要担心信号量、互斥锁之类的东西。这让你的生活变得更轻松，你也因此获得了一些好处。因为这确实取决于你想要解决的问题。
trying to solve. But for web applications, for example, what you really want is to not be waiting on the internet. And if you're not waiting on the internet, then you're pretty close to optimal for your, you know, web service. Because usually you're waiting on the internet to get your request, you know, complete, waiting on the internet to send that request to, or intranet, maybe to send that request to some database, you know, waiting for that database to come back. And so if you eliminate all that weighting, you don't also need to do a lot of multi-processing.
但以Web应用程序为例，你真正想要的是不要在互联网上等待。如果你不需要在互联网上等待，那么你的Web服务就非常接近最优状态了。因为通常你是在等待互联网获取请求，或者等待互联网将请求发送到（可能是内网）某个数据库，然后等待数据库返回结果。所以如果你消除了所有这些等待，你就不需要进行大量的多进程处理。
You don't necessarily need to do a lot of instructions at the same time. So that's kind of the big motivation for async. And so you need a couple of like core building blocks to do asynchronous programming. So you need thread local memory. So in that example I gave, where you're waiting to get some data, you know, over the internet, that data needs a place to go
你不一定需要同时执行大量的指令。这就是异步编程的主要动机。因此，你需要几个核心构建块来进行异步编程。你需要线程本地内存。所以在刚才我举的那个例子中，当你等待通过互联网获取某些数据时，这些数据需要一个存放的地方，
that you know, no other routines can access that data. So for example, you know, one way it's done in Go is through something called Go routines. And so a go routine is not like a new process on your OS. It's not like a whole new process, but it just kind of keeps track of the state of execution in this code. And it also has some thread local or routine local memory.
而且你知道，没有其他例程可以访问这些数据。例如，在Go语言中，实现这一点的方法是通过一种叫做“Go协程”（Goroutines）的东西。Go协程不像操作系统上的新进程，它不是一个全新的进程，它只是跟踪代码中的执行状态。它还拥有一些线程本地或协程本地的内存。
So if you say something like, you know, I want to download this packet of data, from the internet, and then I want to store it in this variable, you know, it has a place to go that it knows is kind of protected. And then while it's doing that protected operation, you know, reading from the internet to some protected thread local memory, it can kind of say, other threads can do other things. Other threads can be reading other things from the internet, or they could be doing arithmetic or whatever, because I know that none of those other threads can affect this operation that I'm doing right here.
所以如果你说，你知道，我想从互联网下载这个数据包，然后我想把它存储在这个变量中，你知道，它有一个它知道是受保护的地方可以去。然后当它在执行那个受保护的操作时，你知道，从互联网读取到一些受保护的线程本地内存，它可以说，其他线程可以做其他事情。其他线程可以从互联网读取其他东西，或者它们可以做算术运算等等，因为我知道那些其他线程都不会影响我在这里做的这个操作。
And so because I know there's no side effects, I can now let those other things go. And so you could have a hundred routines all downloading things from the internet at the same time, even if your program is single-threaded. So you'll hear about blocking versus non-blocking operations. And that basically means, you know, a blocking operation is one where, you know it's not kind of releasing that lock so if you just say imagine you have two kind of routines and both of them are just running a four loop and they're just adding two really large arrays airwise right well those are blocking operations so it's going to happen is the first routine is going to run and it's going to do that entire four loop and that second
因为我知道没有副作用，我现在可以放手让那些其他事情去做了。所以你可以有一百个例程同时从互联网下载东西，即使你的程序是单线程的。所以你会听到关于阻塞与非阻塞操作。这基本上意味着，你知道，阻塞操作是指，你知道它没有释放那个锁，所以如果你想象你有两个例程，它们都在运行一个 for 循环，它们只是在按元素相加两个非常大的数组，好吧，那些是阻塞操作，所以会发生的是第一个例程将运行，它将执行整个 for 循环，而第二个
routine is just going to have to wait. And then when the first routine is completely done, then it'll finish and the second routine will do its four loop. And so you haven't achieved really any parallelism, right? But now take that same scenario, but instead of just adding things in a for loop, you're going to have a four loop that's downloading from the internet. Well, that operation, that download from the internet operation, has been built to be non-blocked. And so in the case of, let's say, like, TypeScript, where it's single-threaded, you know, you have a way of telling the TypeScript or the JavaScript VM, like, hey, I'm about to do something now that is isolated, that's non-blocking. And so, you know, other routines can go and do work while this routine is just frozen on this operation. And then once you've downloaded what you needed from the internet, then you go back.
例程将不得不等待。然后当第一个例程完全完成后，它才会结束，第二个例程才会执行它的 for 循环。所以你并没有真正实现任何并行性，对吧？但现在采用同样的场景，但不是在 for 循环中相加东西，你将有一个从互联网下载的 for 循环。好吧，那个操作，那个从互联网下载的操作，已经被构建为非阻塞的。所以以 TypeScript 为例，它是单线程的，你知道，你有一种方法告诉 TypeScript 或 JavaScript 虚拟机，嘿，我现在要做的这件事是隔离的，是非阻塞的。所以，你知道，其他例程可以去工作，而这个例程只是在这个操作上冻结。然后一旦你从互联网下载了你需要的东西，你就回到
to the virtual machine and say, hey, I'm ready, you know, I'm ready to block and take this, take this, take, take some time. And when it gives you that, that time back, then you can go and copy that information into that variable and all of that. In the case of Python, Python actually has co-routines and threads. And so what that means is, you can actually have multi-threading in Python where you have several different threads accessing memory at the same time. But there is a global interpreter lock. So here's a good way of thinking about it.
虚拟机并说，嘿，我准备好了，你知道，我准备好阻塞并占用一些时间了。当它把时间还给你时，你就可以去把那些信息复制到那个变量中，诸如此类。在 Python 的情况下，Python 实际上有协程和线程。所以这意味着，你实际上可以在 Python 中进行多线程处理，你有几个不同的线程同时访问内存。但有一个全局解释器锁。所以这是一个很好的思考方式。
In the case of, let's say, TypeScript, if you're inside a TypeScript function, you kind of have to wait until there's a non-blocking call. So the example I gave with the for loop, you're just stuck, right? In the case of Python, it would be a little different. If you're using threads, what would happen is the first thread would do part of the for loop, and then it would release, and then the second thread will do part of the four loop and then release. And they'll just kind of, you know, checkerboard this.
以 TypeScript 为例，如果你在一个 TypeScript 函数内部，你必须等到有一个非阻塞调用。所以我给出的 for 循环的例子，你只是卡住了，对吧？在 Python 的情况下，会有点不同。如果你使用线程，会发生的是第一个线程会执行部分 for 循环，然后它会释放，然后第二个线程会执行部分 for 循环然后释放。它们会以某种方式，你知道，像棋盘格一样交错进行。
And so it's not the first one goes till completion. There's sort of this, you know, striping effect. Now, it might take the same amount of time in the end as the TypeScript. version, but, you know, they're both making progress at the same time versus TypeScript is single-threaded. And the way Python achieves this is through a mutex. So this is called the Global Interpreter Lock or Gill. And it basically says, you know, you can have many threads that are all sharing, you know, your VM, but only one of them can execute at a time. So if you wanted to accomplish the same thing with TypeScript.
所以并不是第一个运行到完成。有一种，你知道，条纹效应。现在，最终可能花费的时间和 TypeScript 版本一样，但是，你知道，它们都在同时取得进展，而 TypeScript 是单线程的。Python 实现这一点的方式是通过互斥锁。所以这被称为全局解释器锁或 Gill。它基本上说，你知道，你可以有许多线程都在共享，你知道，你的虚拟机，但一次只能有一个执行。所以如果你想用 TypeScript 完成同样的事情
Imagine the for loop example I gave with TypeScript. So you have a for loop, goes from 1 to $10 million, adds these arrays together. But after every iteration of the for loop, you put a yield. So yield is a special keyword in asynchronous programming. Yield basically says, I just want to give up my time slice. Like, I'm not done yet, but I feel like the right thing to do is to give up my spot and let another thread do some work. And so as a programmer, you might have various reasons for doing this, right?
想象一下我给出的 TypeScript 的 for 循环例子。所以你有一个 for 循环，从 1 到 1000 万，把这些数组加在一起。但在 for 循环的每次迭代之后，你放一个 yield。所以 yield 是异步编程中的一个特殊关键字。Yield 基本上说，我只是想放弃我的时间片。就像，我还没做完，但我认为正确的做法是放弃我的位置，让另一个线程做一些工作。所以作为程序员，你可能有各种各样的理由这样做，对吧？
So imagine if your four loop said, you know, four, you know, A, 1 to 10 million, take these two arrays and add that element together and then yield. So now you're going to get that striping, right? So now the first process will yield. the second one will be able to do one iteration of the four loop and then it will yield back to the first one and so you know the Python multi-threading is the equivalent
所以想象一下如果你的 for 循环说，你知道，for，你知道，A，1 到 1000 万，取这两个数组并把那个元素加在一起然后 yield。所以现在你会得到那种条纹，对吧？所以现在第一个进程会 yield。第二个将能够执行一次 for 循环的迭代，然后它会 yield 回第一个，所以你知道，Python 多线程是等同于
of like having a yield after every operation and so you know the gill kind of enforces all of that that kind of what do you think Patrick any any holes in that that we could cover I think for me my introduction is probably
在每个操作之后有一个 yield，所以你知道，gill 强制执行了所有这些，你觉得怎么样 Patrick，有什么漏洞我们可以涵盖吗？我想对我来说，我的介绍可能
like a bit different but I think it parallels so I don't think it's contrary to what you're saying but I for me it was and you kind of bump into this if you ever do like Arduino programming but like embedded programming and there sometimes the mapping is actually really weird from something like Python to something like running C++ and an embedded microcontroller because it's just sort of like different paradigms like networking is well now it's more common when I was doing it was very rare that you would you know kind of do networking related stuff in in these contexts and there we would talk about like interrupts and so the idea is if you imagine like a microcontroller wants to talk to a sensor that sensor communicates over something called i squared c all it is is like a set of
有点不同，但我认为它是平行的，所以我不认为它与你所说的是相反的，但我对我来说，如果你曾经做过像 Arduino 编程，或者嵌入式编程，你就会碰到这种情况，有时从像 Python 这样的东西到像在嵌入式微控制器上运行 C++ 的映射实际上真的很奇怪，因为这只是某种不同的范式，比如网络，好吧，现在更常见了，在我做的时候，在这些上下文中做与网络相关的事情非常罕见，在那里我们会谈论中断，所以这个想法是，如果你想象一个微控制器想要与传感器通信，那个传感器通过一种叫做 i 2 c 的东西通信，它所做的只是像一组
wires and voltages that move up or down in a certain pattern to send data from like your piece of silicon to like another piece of silicon glued to your like thing with wires or on a printed circuit board or something else. And so you want to measure, let's say, temperature of the room. And you want to record this. And sort of the way that it used to kind of always be done was something called bit banging. And so bit banging would be, hey, I'm a microcontroller. I need to read this. So I'm going to set up an I squared C library in code that says move the voltage on this wire from low to high, wait this amount of time where a wait is go into a loop that is like a certain number of instructions long, time to be like the right amount of wall clock time based
导线和电压，它们以某种模式上下移动，以将数据从你的硅片发送到粘在你的东西上的另一个硅片，用导线或在印刷电路板上或其他东西上。所以你想测量，比如说，房间的温度。你想记录这个。而过去一直这样做的方式被称为位拆裂（bit banging）。所以位拆裂会是，嘿，我是一个微控制器。我需要读取这个。所以我将在代码中设置一个 I 2 C 库，它说将这条线上的电压从低调到高，等待这段时间，其中等待是进入一个循环，它是特定数量的指令长度，时间是基于
on the like rate of the processor. So it's just sitting there doing like no op instructions, but it's running the instructions. It's using all of the power of the full CP. which has like all sorts of peripherals on it. So it's sort of consuming the most. And you sort of like go high for a certain amount of time. Then you go low and you're moving along the sort of data to be sent out to ask for a temperature reading. Then you have to wait and then it starts coming back in. But you can imagine like thousands, tens of thousands of like no-op cycles waiting for like the voltage to move up and down due to capacitance and the rise rate and like the data transmission.
处理器的速率，是正确的挂钟时间。所以它只是坐在那里做像空操作指令，但它在运行指令。它正在使用完整 CPU 的所有功率，它上面有各种各样的外设。所以它有点消耗最大。你有点像在高电平保持一定时间。然后你变低，你正在移动数据以发送出去请求温度读数。然后你必须等待，然后它开始传回来。但你可以想象像成千上万，数以万计的空操作周期等待电压由于电容和上升速率以及数据传输而上下移动。
So the CPU is really bored, but it's sitting there doing nothing, right? And so this is the equivalent of like polling or single threaded and you're doing all of the work in one context. Then people realize, well, we have more sophisticated silicon. Why don't we make like a sort of finite state machine, an accelerator, like another like set of transistors where you sort of said it's thread local memory. The equivalent here is we have to call it a register. So you have a set of registers and you could like write into them, hey, I want to. to send out this data stream and then you would say go and what you could do then is put the CPU into a low power state like go to sleep and then you're going to save power right and then or you could
所以 CPU 真的很无聊，但它坐在那里什么都不做，对吧？所以这等同于轮询或单线程，你在一个上下文中完成所有工作。然后人们意识到，好吧，我们有更复杂的硅片。为什么我们不做一种有限状态机，一个加速器，像另一组晶体管，在那里你设置它是线程本地内存。这里的等价物是我们必须称之为寄存器。所以你有一组寄存器，你可以写进去，嘿，我想发送这个数据流，然后你会说去，然后你可以做的是把 CPU 置于低功耗状态，比如去睡觉，然后你就会节省电力，对吧，或者你可以
go to other processing if you had it but saving power is also really really important a lot of these contexts what's going to happen is the little bit of circuitry is going to like send the thing out it's going to wait for it to come back and then it's going to interrupt and you're going to have a little function that is mapped to say, when this thing is done, it's going to call the instruction that you've loaded into this register. So the instruction there needs to be jump to a function that you wrote. And then that function, when it runs, is going to push the current thread, the current running CPU thing into the stack. It's going to allow you to run some piece of code. And that code could be copy the data out of the registers into a set spot in memory or into a queue or
去进行其他处理，如果你有的话，但节省电力在很多这些上下文中也非常非常重要，会发生的是那一点点电路会把东西发出去，它会等待它回来，然后它会中断，你会有一个映射到说的小函数，当这个东西完成时，它会调用你加载到这个寄存器中的指令。所以那里的指令需要是跳转到你编写的函数。然后那个函数，当它运行时，会把当前线程，当前运行的 CPU 东西推入堆栈。它会允许你运行一段代码。而那段代码可以是把数据从寄存器复制到内存中的特定位置或队列中，或者
just handle, like write it into the flash memory, but that could take a long time so maybe you don't want to do it. And you can imagine as you're handling 10, 15, 20 sort of like peripherals all coming in at different rates, doing all of that and sort of making sure that none of it gets dropped becomes harder and harder if you don't sort of have some mechanism that allows this sort of distributed handling to kind of happen. And so the asynchronous context maps pretty cleanly to what you're saying. You're sending some data to the network and saying, hey, I need you to transmit this.
只是处理，比如把它写进闪存，但这可能需要很长时间，所以也许你不想这样做。你可以想象当你处理 10、15、20 种外设，它们都以不同的速率进来，做所有这些并确保没有一个被丢弃变得越来越难，如果你没有某种机制允许这种分布式处理发生的话。所以异步上下文与你所说的映射得非常干净。你正在发送一些数据到网络并说，嘿，我需要你传输这个。
It's going all the way across the world. It's coming all the way back. And you can sit there and wait for it. And that's called blocking. But under the hood, the blocking is still just basically sitting there. Are you done? Are you done? Are you done? Are you done? Are you done? Are you done? It's not doing any work. It's not bit banging anymore. It's just waiting on the other little processor to do all the work.
它正在穿过世界。它正在一路传回来。你可以坐在那里等它。这被称为阻塞。但在底层，阻塞仍然只是基本上坐在那里。你完成了吗？你完成了吗？你完成了吗？你完成了吗？你完成了吗？你完成了吗？它没有做任何工作。它不再是位拆裂了。它只是在等待另一个小处理器做所有的工作。
And so I think as you kind of pointed out, there's like this clear mapping about blocking versus non-blocking. I think the rest of the conversation becomes in a bit what you're kind of getting into is like there are kind of two ways to handle it. One is sort of in line in the code, I want to ask for something to happen. And while it's happening, that set of consciousness, that execution is just kind of kind of pause there and maybe other stuff can run. And then when it's done, I'm going to pick back up.
所以我认为正如你指出的那样，关于阻塞与非阻塞有一个清晰的映射。我认为对话的其余部分变成了一点你正在进入的内容，即有两种处理它的方法。一种是在代码中内联，我想请求发生某事。当它发生时，那组意识，那次执行只是在那儿暂停，也许其他东西可以运行。然后当它完成时，我会重新开始。
And that is one method. The other method, if you think about like interrupt as a form of like a callback, you could just have like almost a DAG, which is I'm going to ask for something to occur. I'm going to transfer control to that thing. When that thing's done, it's going to call the next stage. Oh, sorry, DACDirected Aclic Graph. So it's just a pipeline. And so you call to the send networking.
这是一种方法。另一种方法，如果你考虑像中断作为一种回调形式，你可以几乎有一个 DAG，即我将请求发生某事。我将把控制权转移给那个东西。当那个东西完成时，它将调用下一个阶段。哦，抱歉，DAG 有向无环图。所以它只是一个管道。所以你调用发送网络。
And when the networking is done, it's going to call some function. But that function is completely different part of the. code, but it's responsible and it has enough context to say, and maybe even pass a little bit of context, hey, I'm getting a response. And when I get a response, this is what I'm going to do. So if you think like a graphical user interface and I say, type in my text to my friend and I click send and then I don't need like control to return really. When my friend sends a response back, that code just needs to know to write it to the screen, like write it into the next line of the message conversation. And so you can kind of have this feedback.
当网络完成时，它将调用某个函数。但那个函数是代码中完全不同的部分，但它负责，并且它有足够的上下文来说，甚至可能传递一点上下文，嘿，我正在得到一个响应。当我得到响应时，这就是我要做的。所以如果你想像图形用户界面，我说，输入我的文字给我的朋友，我点击发送，然后我不需要控制权真的返回。当我的朋友发回响应时，那段代码只需要知道把它写到屏幕上，比如把它写进消息对话的下一行。所以你可以有这种反馈
forward and so you don't really return back to the same point of control and there are these kind of and they can be mixed but these kind of two paradigms where you well i guess there's a third one but like there's this sort of block and wait uh and then control returns there and that can be blocking or asynchronous for allowing for cooperation you can have this like feed forward sort of dagger approach and then the vinyl method is like kind of spoiler we'll get to it in a minute but like the the the sort of future promise where you're getting some state back that somebody else is filling it and you're going to go check on it later you're going to go ask later hey was that done yet or wait for it to be done or something else i think that's like a little bit of like a different handling
向前，所以你并没有真正回到同一个控制点，有这些种类，它们可以混合，但这两种范式，你，好吧，我想有第三种，但有这种阻塞和等待，然后控制权返回那里，那可以是阻塞的或异步的，允许合作，你可以有这种前馈式的 DAG 方法，然后最后的方法是像某种剧透，我们一会儿会讲到，但像那种未来承诺，你得到一些别人正在填充的状态，你稍后会去检查它，你稍后会去问，嘿，那完成了吗，或者等待它完成，或者其他什么，我认为那有点像不同的处理
so there are these kind of different methods but under the hood they're all really the same thing they're just how the programmer wants to relate to that work um and how how you want to set up and what other kinds of things in your system and if you have nothing else to do letting it can be a really good answer in some context. But in other contexts, you have other background processing or other things that need to be handled. And so depending on the paradigm of your program, you'll kind of choose a different asynchronous behavior.
所以有这些不同的方法，但在底层它们实际上都是同一件事，它们只是程序员想要如何与那项工作相关联，以及你想要如何设置以及你的系统中还有什么其他种类的东西，如果你没有其他事情要做，让它等待在某些上下文中可能是一个非常好的答案。但在其他上下文中，你有其他后台处理或其他需要处理的事情。所以根据你的程序范式，你会选择不同的异步行为。
Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. I mean, I'm reminded of, and I should have made this a news article, but if you read like the history of N-G-N-X, so N-G-I-N-X, it's spelled N-G-I-N-X. but basically it's the super fast, you know, web handler, web service handler, and it does routing, proxying, et cetera. And when EngineX was invented or, you know,
是的，是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我想到了，我本应该把它做成新闻文章，但如果你读像 N-G-N-X 的历史，所以 N-G-I-N-X，拼写是 N-G-I-N-X。但基本上它是超快的，你知道，Web 处理程序，Web 服务处理程序，它做路由，代理，等等。当 EngineX 被发明或者，你知道，
was initially being developed, the best thing that was out there for doing web stuff was something kind of like Tomcat. Tomcat is a Java thing. There was other, it's written in other languages. But the way these things would work is, you know, when you started Tomcat, cat it would spin up like let's say eight processes like OS level processes on your computer
最初被开发时，外面做 Web 事情最好的东西是像 Tomcat 那样的东西。Tomcat 是 Java 的东西。还有其他，它是用其他语言编写的。但这些东西的工作方式是，你知道，当你启动 Tomcat 时，它会启动像八个进程，比如你计算机上的操作系统级进程
and it's like okay here's your eight uh processes and and then the main process when it sees there's a new web request it would just send it to one of those eight or all eight of them would listen i'm not sure at that point what exactly happens there but basically one of those eight you know receives a web request handles it, which might include like going to the database and doing other stuff. Maybe it's a, it's over I2C, it's like talking to a temperature sensor or something, and then responds with the response. But because you had eight processes, you could only do eight things at a time. And it could be that all eight of those are waiting on the database.
它就像好的，这是你的八个进程，然后主进程当它看到有一个新的 Web 请求时，它只会把它发送到那八个中的一个，或者所有八个都会监听，我不确定在那一点上到底发生了什么，但基本上那八个中的一个，你知道，接收一个 Web 请求处理它，这可能包括像去数据库做其他事情。也许它是，它是通过 I2C，它就像与温度传感器交谈或类似的东西，然后用响应来响应。但因为你有八个进程，你一次只能做八件事。而且可能是所有八个都在等待数据库。
And you really could add a ninth one or a tenth one without affecting that computer's load, because they're all idle, right? And so EngineX was pretty revolutionary in that they basically said, okay, we're going to create the same eight processes, but we're going to use asynchronous programming. And so, oh, and so, you know, if one of these eight processes is waiting on a database,
你真的可以添加第九个或第十个而不影响那台计算机的负载，因为它们都处于空闲状态，对吧？所以 EngineX 在他们基本上说，好的，我们将创建同样的八个进程，但我们将使用异步编程方面是相当革命性的。所以，哦，所以，你知道，如果这八个进程中的一个正在等待数据库，
then that same process can go and, like, fetch another web request while it's waiting on the database. And so you could actually have, you know, eight processes handling a thousand web requests at the same time instead of eight at the same time. And this like blew everybody's mind. Like I remember we were using Tomcat on something. This is like 2003-ish. And yeah, and just yeah, constantly running into issues with quality of service where you know we'd get um i was working at a online school and so registration day there'd be a ton of people hitting the site and they would inevitably bring it down and uh and so you had this machine that was mostly idle but then also just blocking everyone's
那么同一个进程可以在等待数据库的同时去，比如，获取另一个 Web 请求。所以你实际上可以有，你知道，八个进程同时处理一千个 Web 请求，而不是同时处理八个。这简直让所有人的大脑都炸开了。就像我记得我们在某件事上使用 Tomcat。这大约是 2003 年左右。是的，而且只是，是的，不断遇到服务质量问题，你知道我们会得到，我当时在一家在线学校工作，所以注册日会有很多人访问该网站，他们不可避免地会把它搞垮，而且，所以你有一台大部分时间处于空闲状态的机器，但同时也只是阻塞了每个人的
requests so so engine x was it was amazing um the the thing about it is if you were to do this yourself, like what Patrick was saying, you know, if you were to, you know, to try to implement this asynchronous thing yourself, what you would have to do is, and I'm going to use the higher level terms, this probably doesn't work in Arduino, you could help translate. You'd basically have to say, okay, what things am I doing right now? Okay, I'm doing these eight things. Okay, can I sort of peek at each of these eight things to see if one of them is ready? Oh, the sixth one is ready. Okay, you know, execute that function. Oh, now like that function got a little bit further, but now it's blocked again. Okay, put it back on the list. And so you could imagine like
请求，所以 EngineX，它太棒了，关于它的事情是如果你要自己做这个，就像 Patrick 所说的，你知道，如果你要，你知道，尝试自己实现这个异步东西，你必须做的是，我将使用更高级的术语，这可能在 Arduino 中不起作用，你可以帮忙翻译。你基本上必须说，好的，我现在正在做哪些事情？好的，我正在做这八件事。好的，我可以窥视这八件事中的每一件，看看其中一个是否准备好了吗？哦，第六个准备好了。好的，你知道，执行那个函数。哦，现在那个函数稍微进一步了，但现在它又被阻塞了。好的，把它放回列表。所以你可以想象像
what a nightmare that would be to have to code up, you know, for every application. So, so in this case, like that whole nightmare of just peaking at a zillion different things all the time and finding the one that's available and doing it, like someone else has implemented that nightmare for you so that you can just kind of work at a higher level. Okay, there's a bunch there. That was really good. So I think to be clear, this is all a bit, how do you want like recursive, fractal? So the operating system is doing kind of what you're saying.
那将是一个噩梦，必须为每个应用程序编写代码。所以，在这种情况下，那种一直窥视无数不同东西并找到可用的那个并执行它的噩梦，就像别人已经为你实现了那个噩梦，这样你就可以在更高的水平上工作。好的，那里有很多东西。那真的很好。所以我认为要清楚，这都是一点，你怎么想要像递归，分形？所以操作系统正在做你所说的。
So it has a scheduler, modern computers normally like a preemptive like scheduler, which means exactly that you have some thread running that gets stuck or is not or elapses time and the operating system will like suspend it and run a different thread in order to like time share um and and sort of hopefully some of them are just doing like busy loops polling for something and you're getting a win but there is like some like it's not magic none of this stuff is magic so everyone who always it's kind of one of those two sides of the coin in some cases it sure seems like magic but in other cases you're like I don't get it it like there's still only one CPU and yeah you're right there is really only one CPU so in like
所以它有一个调度程序，现代计算机通常像抢占式调度程序，这意味着正是你有一些线程运行，它被卡住或不是，或者经过时间，操作系统会像挂起它并运行不同的线程以便进行时间共享，而且，而且希望其中一些只是在做像忙循环轮询某事，你正在获胜，但有像一些，它不是魔法，所有这些东西都不是魔法，所以每个人总是，它在某些情况下是硬币的两面之一，它确实看起来像魔法，但在其他情况下你会像我不明白，它仍然只有一个 CPU，是的，你是对的，确实只有一个 CPU，所以在像
your database example, let's say you have sort of like the database is local on disk and you really are kind of bottled. Like let's say you're already maxing out the like hard drive RAM transmit speed from your CPU to RAM. Whether you have one eight, nine, 10, 100 like database jobs queued up, you're not gaining any more throughput by like knowing that you have 100 jobs or knowing that you have eight jobs. Like there's nothing more to do. The trick comes in that that isn't normally the case. It's not that every job coming in needs the database. Some jobs, you will already have a cached answer. It just wants to say, what is the list in your example of like, you know, registration? It's like, what is the list of all classes? Well, you could have
你的数据库例子中，假设你有像数据库在磁盘上是本地的，你确实有点被瓶颈了。就像假设你已经达到了从 CPU 到 RAM 的硬盘 RAM 传输速度的最大值。无论你有一个、八个、九个、十个、100 个像数据库作业排队，你都不会通过知道你有 100 个作业或知道你有八个作业而获得任何更多的吞吐量。就像没有更多的事情可做了。诀窍在于这通常不是这种情况。并不是每个进来的作业都需要数据库。有些作业，你已经有了缓存的答案。它只是想说，列表是什么，在你的例子中，你知道，注册？就像，所有课程的列表是什么？好吧，你可以有
nemenized. You could have cached that like, you know the list from five seconds ago of all possible classes. You don't know their current state, but you know all the things. And so some requests can be quickly turned back around so that the server feels more responsive. And so while you're waiting on the hard drive RAM to transmit database responses, you're sort of getting these things back. And the question becomes a little bit on like the scale, are you running, are you the only thing running in the operating system? Are other things running? Do you have other threads running? Do you have like, there is still a sort of like fundamental limit to how much stuff can happen. And going to an asynchronous solution isn't a cure all,
你可以缓存了那个，你知道五秒前所有可能课程的列表。你不知道它们当前的状态，但你知道所有的事情。所以有些请求可以很快地转回来，这样服务器感觉更响应。所以当你等待硬盘 RAM 传输数据库响应时，你有点在拿回这些东西。问题有点在于规模，你是在操作系统中运行的唯一东西吗？还有其他东西在运行吗？你有其他线程在运行吗？你有像，仍然有一种基本限制，即可以发生多少事情。并且转向异步解决方案并不是万能药，
but it is one of these cases as you're pointing out often we can know more about the problem than the generic operating system solution would give you and so letting 8 OS threads handle something isn't going to be optimal if we know that the work is very heterogeneous because if we are having one in 10 come in that needs a database but it takes a long time to get a database response then as soon as you have the few queued up everybody else even that doesn't need the database is stuck waiting. If you sort of have this sort of asynchronous thing that you're mentioning, you can just burn through the entire queue of everybody who doesn't need the database.
但正如你指出的那样，它是这些情况之一，通常我们可以比通用操作系统解决方案给你的更了解问题，所以让 8 个 OS 线程处理某事不会是最佳的，如果我们知道工作是非常异构的，因为如果我们有十分之一进来需要数据库，但获得数据库响应需要很长时间，那么一旦你有几个排队，每个人，即使是不需要数据库的人，也被卡住等待。如果你有这种你提到的异步东西，你可以直接烧掉所有不需要数据库的人的整个队列。
People who need the database may still get a failure, right? Like, you know, they may still have a timeout. But overall, your metrics are better. The responsiveness feels better. And you can kind of guarantee you're maximizing the proper throughput. Yeah, yeah, totally. I mean, this is also like there's a, dynamic at play here, which is like throughput versus latency.
需要数据库的人可能仍然会失败，对吧？就像，你知道，他们可能仍然有超时。但总的来说，你的指标更好。响应性感觉更好。而且你可以保证你正在最大化适当的吞吐量。是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，这也是像这里有一个动态在起作用，即吞吐量与延迟。
So imagine. Oh, yeah. Okay, good. Yeah, like, imagine like the connection. Imagine like the database is like a giant sewer pipe, but the water can only go, you know, one meter a second. And so, you know, you could put like a ton of, of water through, but it can only go through at a certain rate.
所以想象。哦，是的。好的，是的，就像，想象像连接。想象像数据库是一个巨大的下水道管道，但水只能走，你知道，一米一秒。所以，你知道，你可以放像一吨的水通过，但它只能以一定的速率通过。
And so that's where, yeah, having like a zillion connections to the database actually better because you're just hiding all of that latency. But you're right. With asynchronous programming, you do run into a lot of problems around, you know, now you can do a thousand things, but that also means that potentially there's a thousand things
所以这就是，是的，有像无数连接到数据库实际上更好，因为你只是隐藏了所有那些延迟。但你是对的。使用异步编程，你确实会遇到很多问题，关于，你知道，现在你可以做一千件事，但这也意味着潜在地有一千件事
that are in a bad state, or if there's a bottleneck further down in the chain, then now all those thousand things are sort of fighting for resources. So even in asynchronous solutions, like if you look at fast API, for example, even though it's asynchronous and you could handle a thousand requests on one thread if you wanted to, even there you would specify a limit. So you typically would say something like, if I have, I'm just going to make up a number, if I have 32 requests simultaneously on this machine and a 33rd comes in, I'm just going to reject it. and return a HTTP 503, and then my client will call again and hopefully get a different machine. Because even though the machine might not even be very busy, you just don't want to be in a weird situation where there's a thousand things that aren't getting done, because that's usually a sign
处于糟糕的状态，或者如果链条下游有瓶颈，那么现在所有那一千件事都在争夺资源。所以即使在异步解决方案中，比如如果你看 fast API，例如，即使它是异步的，如果你愿意，你可以在一个线程上处理一千个请求，即使在那里你也会指定一个限制。所以你通常会说类似，如果我有，我只是编一个数字，如果我在这台机器上有 32 个并发请求，而第 33 个进来了，我只会拒绝它。并返回一个 HTTP 503，然后我的客户端会再次调用并希望得到一台不同的机器。因为即使机器可能甚至不是很忙，你只是不想处于一种奇怪的情况，即有一千件事没有完成，因为那通常是一个迹象
that something else is wrong. So asynchronous, to your point, it's not a free lunch. You do have to, you know, now that you've been given this power, you do have to use it responsibly. Yeah, you bring up a good thing that was like an interplay here. We didn't have it in notes, but like queue management and there's like stacked up cues everywhere. So as you're going to mention, you're going to have like a load balancer and the load balancer will have like a little bit of a queue at sending stuff. If you just consume a thousand things, even though you can't handle them, some other server may have finished everything it's doing and you're just like holding those thousand waiting for expiration basically. And in reality, as you said, if you returned an error code after a certain amount, it'll just run back to the load balancer and hopefully get assigned to a machine that like isn't having an issue or isn't overloaded or whatever and those have their own cues so there's like this very interesting whole system dynamic the other thing about asynchronous program although it is like important to know about and be aware of is you do have to just like multi-threading you do have to be concerned about like race conditions data safety issues depending on what all is happening right so
表明其他事情出了问题。所以异步，就你的观点而言，它不是免费的午餐。你确实必须，你知道，既然你已经被赋予了这种力量，你确实必须负责任地使用它。是的，你提出了一个很好的事情，就像这里的一个相互作用。我们笔记里没有它，但像队列管理，到处都有堆积的队列。正如你将要提到的，你将有一个负载均衡器，负载均衡器在发送东西时会有一点队列。如果你只是消耗一千件事，即使你不能处理它们，另一台服务器可能已经完成了它正在做的所有事情，而你只是像保持那些一千个等待过期基本上。实际上，正如你所说，如果你在一定数量后返回错误代码，它只会跑回负载均衡器并希望被分配到一台没有问题或没有过载的机器，而那些有它们自己的队列，所以有这种非常有趣的整个系统动态，关于异步程序的另一件事，虽然它像了解和意识到很重要，但你确实必须就像多线程一样，你确实必须担心像竞争条件、数据安全问题，取决于正在发生的一切，对吧？所以
So you can imagine I send a network request and then I have an update from the user. I want to do something different. I've changed my state. I send the new networking request that I kind of want to supersede, but the old one comes back. And I think it's an answer to, you know what I mean? Like you have to manage that, wait a minute, like I have to be really careful. I'm doing more than one thing at a time. And so you can end up with all of the traditional things you would hear about related to sort of thread
所以你可以想象我发送一个网络请求，然后我有一个来自用户的更新。我想做不同的事情。我已经改变了我的状态。我发送我有点想取代的新网络请求，但旧的那个回来了。我认为这是对的，你知道我的意思吗？就像你必须管理那个，等一下，就像我必须非常小心。我一次做不止一件事。所以你最终可能会得到所有你听说过的与线程相关的传统事情
safety, being careful, making sure that you know, you're aware of whether the data structures like cues and other things you're using are multi-thread safe, even if you're only doing async stuff, because you can end up in these weird situations where out-of-sequence stuff is occurring or overrides or you just even be aware that it does add a lot more complexity to the system. But there is a lot of gains to be made in many situations. Yeah, totally. And this is really what separates kind of like masters of their craft from apprentices. You know, it's like all of the lessons learned around, oh, you know, we got burned this way or that way or we, you know, the database kind of like fell over because we weren't monitoring it. And what it really comes down
安全，小心，确保你知道，你意识到你正在使用的数据结构，如队列和其他东西，是否是多线程安全的，即使你只是在做异步事情，因为你最终可能会处于这些奇怪的情况，即发生乱序的事情或覆盖，或者你甚至意识到它确实给系统增加了更多的复杂性。但在许多情况下，有很多收益可以获得。是的，完全正确。这确实是区分像手艺大师和学徒的东西。你知道，就像所有关于，哦，你知道，我们以这种或那种方式被烧伤，或者我们，你知道，数据库有点像倒塌了，因为我们没有监控它。而它真正归结为
to is just setting up a ton of monitoring and constantly tweaking. And constantly tweaking. the knobs. You know, it's, if, if, um, if the machine is like mostly idle, then maybe it can handle more processes, but, um, you know, if processes are getting backed up, why are they getting backed up? And so there isn't, uh, like a, there isn't a system you're going to build that, that has concurrency that's going to work perfectly for the first time and forever. You know, as, as the load profile of changes, um, you'll have to, adapt to it and it becomes kind of a living system. This is this is pretty unavoidable. So async, you know, helps with, you know, all of the mistakes that come from multi-process, you know,
的只是设置大量的监控并不断调整。并不断调整旋钮。你知道，如果，如果，嗯，如果机器大部分时间处于空闲状态，那么也许它可以处理更多的进程，但是，嗯，你知道，如果进程被备份，为什么它们被备份？所以没有，嗯，没有一个系统你会构建，它有并发性，第一次就能完美工作并且永远工作。你知道，随着，随着负载配置文件的变化，嗯，你将不得不适应它，它变成了一种活的系统。这是这是相当不可避免的。所以异步，你知道，有助于，你知道，所有来自多进程的错误，你知道，
as sync, you know, you can eliminate a lot of those as as candidates. Like if we were doing our, if we were basically building async ourselves, we'd have to wonder, oh, did I get the process pool correctly? Am I releasing the semaphore at the right time? And so because of async, you're, you don't have to worry about that, but the consequences you still have to deal with. You bring up a really good point, actually. I think if you're going to go to this approach, so there are some like UI frameworks,
作为同步，你知道，你可以消除很多那些作为候选者。就像如果我们正在做我们的，如果我们基本上是在自己构建异步，我们必须想知道，哦，我是否正确地得到了进程池？我是否在正确的时间释放信号量？所以因为异步，你，你不必担心那个，但后果你仍然必须处理。你确实提出了一个很好的观点，实际上。我认为如果你要采用这种方法，所以有一些像 UI 框架，
I feel are much more commonly written in an async at the framework level because you want to make sure that the user interface stays responsive. So you shouldn't ever do anything blocking. And so they're actually really set up from the start to be asynchronous. But people who write that, well,
我觉得在框架层面更常见的是用异步编写，因为你想确保用户界面保持响应。所以你不应该做任何阻塞的事情。所以它们实际上从一开始就被设置为异步的。但编写它的人，嗯，
I should say a lot of people I work don't write UIs. they're not actually even familiar with that. As you pointed out, if you ask them about it, they wouldn't really be aware of like the nuances of these tradeoffs and the decisions and the complexities and measuring and all of the parameter, like having reasonable parameters and monitoring whether or not like they're set well would just be stuff not present.
我应该说我工作的很多人不写 UI。他们甚至不熟悉那个。正如你指出的那样，如果你问他们关于它的事情，他们不会真正意识到这些权衡和决定以及复杂性和测量以及所有参数的细微差别，比如拥有合理的参数和监控它们是否设置得好将只是不存在的东西。
So it is really weird. like on the one hand it's common enough that you would sort of say like it's in every UI framework to have like asynchronous stuff what do you mean like people don't know what it is but it's like this very weird division of practitioners where sort of like I think there are whole classes of people who go a very long career without really getting into any of it yeah yeah totally um which is why you need to subscribe to programming throwdown it's a perfect segue to our outro.
所以这真的很奇怪。就像一方面它足够常见，以至于你会说像每个 UI 框架都有像异步东西，你是什么意思，人们不知道它是什么，但它就像从业者的这种非常奇怪的分工，某种程度上，我认为有整类的人在没有真正进入任何这些的情况下度过了非常长的职业生涯，是的，是的，完全正确，嗯，这就是为什么你需要订阅 Programming Throwdown，这是我们结尾的完美过渡。
I mean, we, you know, I feel like we gave a pretty good background. I think, you know, the sort of maybe the call to action here is really learn ASync programming. I mean, if you,
我的意思是，我们，你知道，我觉得我们给出了一个相当好的背景。我认为，你知道，那种也许这里的行动号召是真正学习异步编程。我的意思是，如果你，
if you're doing UI stuff, you pretty much have to. I think it's at the point now where I think Android and iOS, if you try to do a network request on the main thread, it'll just like give you an error like a runtime error um it just literally will not let you use the main thread to do non-blocking stuff um so so it's a non-starter but but even if you're
如果你在做 UI 事情，你几乎必须这样做。我认为现在已经到了我认为 Android 和 iOS 的地步，如果你尝试在主线程上做网络请求，它只会像给你一个错误，像运行时错误，嗯，它字面上不会让你使用主线程做非阻塞事情，所以所以这是一个非启动器，但但即使你
doing anything with distributed anything with queue processing um you'll have to you'll encounter this in some way shape or form so so if this is all new definitely dive in this is an area that's worth learning. I think with with um, um, I think with AI and agents and all of these things, it's going to become even more important, you know, an agent might send a text message and wait to get a response from somebody and it can't just block the machine while it's doing that, right? You want you want to run like 10,000 agents on one machine. So, uh, so super important area. I think that
正在做任何与分布式有关的事情，任何与队列处理有关的事情，你都必须以某种形式或方式遇到这种情况，所以所以如果这一切都是新的，一定要深入研究，这是一个值得学习的领域。我认为随着，随着，嗯，嗯，我认为随着 AI 和代理以及所有这些东西，它将变得更加重要，你知道，一个代理可能会发送短信并等待得到某人的响应，它不能只是在做那个时阻塞机器，对吧？你想你想在一台机器上运行像 10,000 个代理。所以，嗯，超级重要的领域。我认为
it's definitely something that's worth researching. And if you have any questions, you can always go on Discord. The Discord channel is getting more engagement. I always try to reply to stuff
它绝对是值得研究的东西。如果你有任何问题，你总是可以在 Discord 上。Discord 频道正在获得更多的参与。我总是尝试回复东西
on there. So check us out on Discord. She's just an email. And it's a great cover in this. Yep. Thank you everyone. All right. Catch you later. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share like and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里。所以去 Discord 上看看我们。她只是发一封电子邮件。这是一个很好的涵盖这个。是的。谢谢大家。好的。稍后见。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供对我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。